I WANT TO WELCOME EVERYONE TO
THE THURSDAY APRIL TWENTY FIFTH
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN MEETING.
OF THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE.
ONE APPRECIATE EVERYONE FOR
COMING OUT THIS MORNING WE HAVE
ONE ITEM TODAY AND THAT IS AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO OF WHICH I
AM THE AUTHOR.
I WANT TO JUST AS A HOUSEKEEPING
MENTION A FEW THINGS.
AB THIRTY SIX WAS POLL TODAY AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR AND IT
HAS BEEN SENT BACK TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A NUMBER OF GROUND RULES
FOR THIS COMMITTEE BECAUSE I
KNOW THAT THERE ARE MANY MANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT HAVE
TYPICALLY NOT COME TO THIS
COMMITTEE ROOM.
OF FIRST OF ALL WITH REGARDS TO
TODAY -- IT I AM GOING TO
SHORTLY TURN THE GAVEL OVER TO
OUR VICE CHAIR MISTER DIP.
AND I WILL BE MAKING A
PRESENTATION ON THIS BILL ALONG
WITH OUR WITNESSES.
EACH SIDE TODAY IS GOING TO HAVE
THREE WITNESSES AND A TOTAL OF
TEN MINUTES EACH.
FOR THEIR PRESENTATIONS THAT
WILL BE FOLLOWED BY AN INITIAL
COMMITTEE DISCUSSION OF THAT IS
WHAT THE COMMITTEE WOULD LIKE TO
DO.
AND THEN WE WILL MOVE TO PUBLIC
COMMENT.
LET ME SAY A FEW THINGS ABOUT
PUBLIC COMMENTS AND START WITH
THE FOLLOWING.
THIS IS DEMOCRACY.
WHAT WE EXPECTED DEMOCRACIES FOR
EVERYONE TO BE ABLE TO EXPRESS
THEIR PERSPECTIVE?
BUT WE ALSO EXPECT IN OUR
DEMOCRACY IS WE EXPECT RESPECT.
WE EXPECT STABILITY.
AND WE EXPECT PEOPLE NOT TO
INTERRUPT EACH OTHER.
AND SO WHAT WE'RE ASKING FOR
TODAY AND THIS IS HOW WE
TYPICALLY DO PUBLIC COMMENT WHEN
WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE.
THAT WISH TO EXPRESS OUR
PERSPECTIVE.
IS WE'RE GONNA ASK EVERYONE IN
PUBLIC COMMENT TO LINE UP AT
THAT MICROPHONE.
WILL ONLY BE ABLE TO DO THIS IN
BATCHES.
GONNASTART WITH INDIVIDUALS
HERE IN THIS ROOM AND WE'RE
GOING TO ASK YOU TO STATE.
YOUR NAME. ONE AFFILIATION.
AND WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE THE BILL SO I WILL GIVE
THE EXAMPLE.
I'M DAVID CHIU.
FROM SAN FRANCISCO AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
THAT IS WHAT WE'RE GONNA ASK YOU
TO DO IF YOU DO ANYTHING BEYOND
THAT WE'RE GONNA CUT YOUR
MICROPHONE OFF SO THAT WE GIVE
EVERYONE EQUAL TIME.
WE YOU CANNOT WAIVE SIGNS
BECAUSE THAT INTERFERES WITH THE
ABILITY OF OTHER PEOPLE TO SEE.
AND AGAIN WE'RE ASKING FOR
RESPECT.
I KNOW THAT EVERYONE WOULD LIKE
TO SAY MORE THAN WHAT.
THAT WHAT I JUST SAID BUT IF WE
DON'T DO THAT WE'RE NOT GONNA.
BE ABLE TO MOVE THROUGH THE
HUNDREDS OF INDIVIDUALS THAT WE
HAVE HERE AND THAT IS HOW WE
CONDUCT BUSINESS IN THIS HOUSE.
SO WITH THAT.
WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO THE
PRESENTATION.
AND I'M GONNA TURN -- THE THE
THE PODIUM OVER -- TO OUR VICE
CHAIR BUT BEFORE WE DO THAT LET
US TAKE ROLL MADAM SECRETARY
COULD PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. TO
HEAR TO HEAR DEEP.
DEEP HERE GABRIEL.
GABRIEL HERE GLORIA GLORIA HERE
KILEY.
THE MON.
LIMóN HERE MAIENSCHEIN.
MENTION HERE QUIRK SILVA.
EXCELLENT HERE
.
WE WILL NOW TAKE UP FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE AB.
ONE FOUR EIGHTY TWO MISTER --
MISTER CHAIRMAN YOU MAY BEGIN
[inaudible]
YOU COLLEAGUES.
FIRST OF ALL LET ME JUST SAY I
APPRECIATE ALL OF YOU AND YOUR
DEEP CONSIDERATION OF THESE
ISSUES AND LET ME START WITH THE
FOLLOWING.
EVERYONE OF US IN THIS ROOM KNOW
THAT IN CALIFORNIA AT THIS TIME
IN HISTORY IT'S ALMOST A CLICHE
TO SAY THAT WE ARE IN THE MIDST
OF A HOUSING CRISIS.
THE WORST HOUSING CRISIS IN OUR
STATE'S HISTORY.
BUT WE ARE.
WE'RE NOT ONLY A HOUSING CRISIS
WHEN HOMELESSNESS CRISIS.
AND WHEN ATTENDED CRISIS AND
INNOVATION CRISIS.
MOST OF CALIFORNIANS SEVENTEEN
MILLION TENANTS DO NOT HAVE SAFE
SECURE AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
WE HAVE MILLIONS OF TENANTS WERE
ONE RENT INCREASE AWAY FROM
BEING ABLE TO PUT FOOD ON THE
TABLE.
GET HEALTH CARE OR AT THE RISK
OF BECOMING HOMELESS.
I OFTEN SAY THAT THE WAY OUT OF
THIS PROBLEM REQUIRES THE THREE
PIECE THAT WE NEED TO PRODUCE A
LOT MORE HOUSING.
PRESERVE THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WE HAVE AND PROTECT VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS FROM LOSING THEIR
HOUSING.
THERE ARE SOME WHO SAY WE SHOULD
ONLY FOCUS ON PRODUCTION.
BUT I WOULD SAY EVEN IF TODAY WE
COULD ENTITLED ALL OF THE THREE
AND A HALF MILLION UNITS OF
HOUSING THAT WE ARE SHORT ON IN
CALIFORNIA.
IT WILL TAKE YEARS IF NOT
DECADES TO BUILD.
AND IN THE MEANTIME WE NEED
PROTECTIONS NOW FOR CALIFORNIANS.
THIS BILL OUR BILL.
IS A BILL TO ADDRESS RENT
GOUGING.
OUR ANTI REGARDING BILL IS A
CRITICAL PROTECTION THAT WILL
HELP RENTERS WHILE STILL
ALLOWING LANDLORDS TO MAKE A
HEALTHY RETURN.
IT IS NOT RENT CONTROL.
IT IS MEANT TO PROTECT TENANTS
AGAINST THE MOST EGREGIOUS RENT
INCREASES NO MATTER WHERE THEY
RENTS ARE WHAT KIND OF UNIT THEY
LIVE IN.
OUR BILL IS BASED ON A LAW THAT
HAS BEEN ON THE BOOKS SINCE THE
EIGHTEEN SEVENTIES FOR NEARLY A
HUNDRED FIFTY YEARS.
AN ANTI PRICE GOUGING LAW.
THAT PREVENTS INCREASES IN RENT
OR OTHER PRICES OR GOODS BY MORE
THAN 10%.
AFTER AN EMERGENCY A DAD'S ASTOR
OR A DECLARED STATE OF EMERGENCY.
GIVEN THE MILLIONS OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE STRUGGLING EVERYDAY IT'S
CLEAR THAT WE ARE IN A HOUSING
EMERGENCY AND WE HAVE TO ACT
ACCORDINGLY.
MORE TALK FOR A MOMENT ABOUT WHO
THIS BILL [inaudible]
WOULD HELP.
OF CALIFORNIA SEVENTEEN MILLION
RENTERS.
WE HAVE TWO MILLION WHO ARE
PROTECTED BY RENT CONTROL.
BUT FIFTEEN MILLION WHO ARE NOT.
THIS IS A BILL THAT FOCUSED ON
THOSE FIFTEEN MILLION.
WE ALL KNOW THAT RENTS HAVE BEEN
INCREASING MUCH FASTER THAN
INCOMES IN THE PAST TEN YEARS
ALONE THE MEDIAN RENTS IN
CALIFORNIA.
HAS INCREASED BY OVER A THIRD
WHILE THE MEDIAN INCOME HAS
REMAINED FLAT.
AND IT'S ACTUALLY DECREASED FOR
MANY CALIFORNIANS.
AS A RESULT OVER HALF OF RENTERS
OVER 80% OF LOW INCOME RENTERS
ARE RENT BIRD.
WHICH MEANS A PAY OVER A THIRD
OF THEIR INCOME TOWARD RENTS.
ACCORDING TO RECENT MCKINSEY
GLOBAL INSTITUTE STUDY.
EVERY YEAR CALIFORNIANS ARE
PAYING FIFTY BILLION DOLLARS
MORE FOR HOUSING THEN THEY ARE
ABLE TO AFFORD.
THIS MEANS CHOICES THAT NO
FAMILY SHOULD BE FORCED TO MAKE
WHETHER TO KEEP A ROOF OVER
THEIR HEADS OR KEEP THEIR
FAMILIES FED HEALTHY AND
EDUCATED.
NOW LET ME SAY THIS.
THIS BILL IS NOT A SILVER BULLET
FOR ALL OF THESE CONCERNS BUT WE
DO THINK THAT WILL GO A
SIGNIFICANT WAY TOWARD
PROTECTING.
THOSE FIFTEEN MILLION PEOPLE
THAT DO NOT HAVE RENT CONTROL.
EIGHTY FOUR EIGHTY TWO
ESTABLISHES A MAXIMUM RENT
INCREASE IN RENTS.
THAT IS SET OUT THE CONSUMER
PRICE INDEX PLUS 5%.
GIVEN THAT THE AVERAGE ANNUAL
INCREASE IN CPI IS BEEN BETWEEN
TWO AND A HALF 23%.
IT FLUCTUATES WITH THE ECONOMY
SO IN HARD TIMES THIS CAP COULD
BE AT 5% IN A HOT ECONOMY LIKE
THE ONE WE HAVE TODAY
POTENTIALLY 10%.
AND IN KEEPING WITH THE PRICE
GOUGING LAW THAT I MENTION
BEFORE WE ESTABLISH A MAXIMUM
INCREASE IN ANY YEAR OF 10%.
WHAT THIS CAP DOES IS PREVENT
THE MOST EGREGIOUS INCREASES IN
RENTS?
A 15% 25% 50% A 100% 2100% THAT
WE'VE BEEN HEARING ABOUT ALL TOO
COMMONLY.
IT PROVIDES A SENSE OF CERTAINTY
AND STABILITY SO FAMILIES WOULD
NOT NEED TO LIVE IN THE FEAR OF
A GIANT UNKNOWN INCREASE OF RENT
RIGHT AROUND THE CORNER.
THAT COULD FORCE THEM OUT OF
THEIR HOME. FOR LANDLORDS THIS
BILL WOULD STILL ENABLE THEM NOT
JUST A FAIR RATE OF RETURN BUT A
HEALTHY RETURN ON THEIR
INVESTMENT.
WHEN I FIRST INTRODUCED THIS
BILL WE INTRODUCED IT AT CPI
PLUS BLANK WE DID NOT PUT A
NUMBER IN?
I HAD MANY CONVERSATIONS WITH
ALL STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT WHAT THE
APPROPRIATE NUMBER WAS.
LET ME SAY THAT CPI PLUS FIVE
CAME FROM THREE SOURCES.
FIRST THE IDEA FOR THIS BILL AND
THE CONCEPT OF CPI PLUS FIVE
CAME FROM A PAPER.
BY THE UC BERKELEY TURNER CENTER
FOR HOUSING INNOVATION CALLED
FINDING COMMON GROUND AND RENT
CONTROL.
SECOND ALMOST IN ALL AFTER
ALMOST A TWO YEAR NEGOTIATION OF
THE BAY AREA BETWEEN TYPICALLY
WARREN STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING
RENTS HOUSING INDUSTRY PLAYERS.
TENANTS AND PROGRESSIVE EQUITY
ADVOCATES LABOR PRIVATE AND
NONPROFIT HOUSING DEVELOPERS THE
BAY AREA CASA COMPACT ALSO
PROPOSED CPI PLUS FIVE AS
SOMETHING THAT WAS AGREED UPON
BY THE PARTIES.
THIRD I'VE ASKED BOTH SIDES OF
THIS DEBATE FOR DATA TO JUSTIFY
NUMBER.
I WAS PROVIDED DATA FROM HOUSING
NOW.
DATA FROM THE BUREAU OF LABOR
STATISTICS THAT SHOWS THAT CPI
PLUS 5% IS ON AVERAGE.
A 100% HIGHER THAN THE AVERAGE
MEDIAN RENTS INCREASE FOR EACH
OF THE STATE'S LARGEST REGIONS.
OVER THE PAST TEN YEARS AN
ANNUAL RENT INCREAE OF CPI PLUS
5% WOULD HAVE CUMULATIVELY
INCREASED RENT. FOUR TIMES
FASTER THAN THE ACTUAL.
REGIONAL MEDIAN RENT INCREASE IN
CALIFORNIA.
LET ME JUST CLOSE BY THANKING
EVERYONE FOR THIS CONVERSATION I
WANT TO THANK BOTH SIDES.
I KNOW THIS IS BEEN A DIFFICULT
CONVERSATION.
BUT AT THE END THE DAY MY
PROFOUND HOPE IS THAT WE PROVIDE
THE CERTAINTY THE CALIFORNIA
RENTERS NEED.
SO THAT THEY WON'T RECEIVE AN
EXORBITANT RENT INCREASE WELL WE
ALLOW PROPERTY OWNERS TO MAKE A
FAIR RATE OF RETURN ON THEIR
INVESTMENT.
AND WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO TURN
IT OVER TO OUR WITNESSES.
STARTING FIRST WITH ELSA STEVENS
WHO IS A TENANTS FOLLOWED BY
CENTER D. AS FROM SEIU AND SAY
SER DS FROM THE BUILDING TRADES.
THEY COULD LIKE GERMAN UP BUT BE.
BEFORE YOU WITNESS -- AGAIN --
IT'S ONE OF MY EVERYONE AGAIN
THAT COLLECTIVELY OF THE THREE
OF YOU HAVE A TEN MINUTES OR SO
WE HAVE ABOUT.
A THREE MINUTES THAT ALLOCATED
FOR EACH ONE OF YOU AND THE
CLERK WHEN I WAS.
A TECH WORLD YOU MAY BEGIN MA'AM.
I'M CONFUSED DO I HAVE THREE
MINUTES OR TEN MINUTES YOU HAVE
THREE MINUTES.
I'M ALSO STEVENS MY HUSBAND AND
I LIVE IN A ONE BEDROOM
APARTMENT IN A ONE HUNDRED
NINETY TWO UNIT COMPLEX CALLED
HERITAGE PARK AT HILLTOP IN
RICHMOND.
NEITHER OF US ARE TRUST FUND
BABIES WE WORKED ALL OUR LIVES
AND PAID INTO SOCIAL SECURITY.
MY HUSBAND WAS A COMPUTER SYSTEM
SALESMAN FOR MOST OF HIS ADULT
LIFE UNTIL HE HAD A QUADRUPLE
BYPASS.
WHEN WE RETIRED SIX YEARS AGO IT
WAS PRIORITY FOR US TO LIVE IN
YOUR THIRTY ONE YEAR OLD
AUTISTIC SON WHO IS CURRENTLY
LEARNING TO TIE HIS SHOE LACES?
WE MOVED TO HERITAGE PARK
ADVERTISED AS QUOTE UNQUOTE
QUALITY AFFORDABLE APARTMENT
COMMUNITY FOR SENIOR LIVING. TO
LIVE HERE YOU MUST BE OVER FIFTY
FIVE YEARS OF AGE AND CANNOT
HAVE INCOME ABOVE A MODERATE
LEVEL.
WE THOUGHT OUR PRAYERS HAVE BEEN
ANSWERED AND FOR THE FIRST FEW
YEARS.
THE RENT.
ONLY WENT UP A LITTLE BIT EACH
YEAR THEN IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
ARE IT WENT UP 7% PER MONTH MOST
OF US ARE SENIORS ON FIXED
INCOMES AND HAVE EXHAUSTED ALL
OUR MISTAKES.
ON LUXURIES.
LIKE CAR REPAIRS AND MEDICINE.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE NEXT YEAR
USA PROPERTIES DECIDED TO RAISE
OUR RENT 12% THEY AWOKE A ONE
HUNDRED NINETY TWO UNIT.
COMMUNITY GIANT.
SENIORS ARE LUCKY TO GET A ONE
OR 2% RAISE FOR IT FROM SOCIAL
SECURITY MOST OF US HAVE MEDICAL
CONDITIONS AND IN CASE YOU
HAVEN'T HEARD.
WALMART IS NO LONGER HIRING
READERS.
MY HUSBAND AND I ARE OR ALREADY
SPENDING 40% OF OUR INCOME ON
RENT MANY OF OUR NEIGHBORS
SEVENTY OR EIGHTY A FRIEND OF
MINE IN THE BUILDING MRS OVERTON
IN HER EIGHTIES HAS ONLY HUNG ON
BECAUSE HER CHILDREN NOW COVER
HALF THE RENT.
THE FOOD BANK COMES TO OUR
COMMUNITY.
A 19% RENT INCREASE IN TWO YEARS
WOULD MAKE MOST OF US INSTANTLY
HOMELESS ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S.
THAT IS NOT AN EXAGGERATION THAT
IS A FACT.
HERITAGE PARK AT HILLTOP WAS
BUILT IN NINETEEN NINETY FIVE
PER COSTA HAWKINS.
RICHMOND COULD NOT COVER US
UNDER ITS RENT CONTROL LAWS BUT
BECAUSE WE ALL PEOPLE ORGANIZE
AND REYES SUCH A STINK.
USA PROPERTIES LORD OUR RENT
HIKE FROM 12% 23% BUT EVEN THEN
WE LOST FRIENDS AND NEIGHBORS
THEY HAD TO MOVE.
NOW WE'RE HEARING THAT USA
PROPERTY THINKS 5% OF THIS YEAR
IS A KINDNESS. 7% IN 1720173% IN
20185% IN.
NOW EQUALS 15% NOBODY'S SOCIAL
SECURITY INCREASES 15% IN THE IN
THREE YEARS. THIRTY SECOND MA'AM.
THIRTY SECONDS OKAY -- YOU GOT
TO MOVE THESE BILLS WE ALL --
NOT NOT ONE WILL SOLVE ALL THE
PROBLEMS.
WE NEED ALL.
THREE WE SENIORS CAN'T OUT SPEND
THE CORPORATE LANDLORD LOBBY
THERE'S FLOODING THIS CAPITAL
WITH MILLIONS OF DOLLARS EVERY
YEARS NOT JUST IN LOBBYING BUT
IN CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS.
BUT I'LL LET YOU KNOW SOMETHING
WE CAN'T AFFORD TO GIVE UP GIVE
IN OR AND OUR NUMBERS ARE
GROWING THE PEOPLE OF THIS STATE
WANT RENT CONTROL THANK YOU IT'S
TIME FOR OUR ELECTED OFFICIALS
TO DECIDE WHOSE SIDE ARE YOU ON
THANK YOU WITH EVEN.
OF WITHIN A RADIUS.
HI GOOD MORNING -- MY NAME IS
SEND IDEAS ON VICE PRESIDENT
WITH SEIU UNITED SERVICE WORKERS
WEST WE REPRESENT FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND CONTRACTED OUT WORKERS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND I'M HERE ALSO ON TO LECTURE
ON THE LIFE SCA YOU CALIFORNIA
SUPPORTING AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO AND WE'VE ALSO MADE THE
ENTIRE KEEP.
ON FAMILIES HOMES LEGISLATIVE
PACKAGE ONE OF OUR TOP
PRIORITIES.
AND FOR MANY OF YOU YOU KNOW
SOME FOLKS WILL SAY WELL WHY IS
LABOR IN HERE -- IN SUCH BIG
NUMBERS REPRESENT TEAM --
TALKING ABOUT HOUSING AND IT'S
NO LONGER ENOUGH TO SUPPORT AS
AN IN SUPPORT WORKING FAMILIES
JUST WITH OUR CONTRACT CAMPAIGNS --
ORGANIZING EFFORTS WERE HEARING
DAY IN AND DAY OUT FROM OUR
MEMBERS THAT THERE WE SURVEYED
OUR MEMBERS THE OUR HOME AND
SECURE THEIR WAITING PAYCHECK TO
PAYCHECK. TO SEE IF THEY CAN
STAY IN THEIR APARTMENTS AND
THAT IS A REALITY THAT OUR
MEMBERS THAT CALIFORNIA'S CAN NO
LONGER CONTINUE TO EXPERIENCE.
ON CALIFORNIA'S LEADERS IN MANY
DIFFERENT WAYS THIS IS A THIS IS
A I HAVE MOMENT IN TIME WHERE WE
ARE BEING TESTED COULD WE
LEADING COULD WE HAVE
CALIFORNIANS LIVE HERE COULD WE
HAVE.
SECURITY OFFICERS WHO ARE MOSTLY
BLACK MEN WHO ARE AMONG THE
HIGHEST NUMBERS OF FOLKS THAT
ARE.
HOMELESS OR ABOUT TO BE HOMELESS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHAT
ARE WE DOING FOR BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES APART IMMIGRANT
WORKERS HERE.
I KNOW THAT WE'VE DONE.
A WHOLE LOT OF PEACE PEACE IS TO
MOVE OUR COMMUNITIES FORWARD BUT
WHEN WE HEAR FROM OUR MEMBERS
FROM HOME CARE WORKERS THIS
MORNING WHO ARE ELDERLY ST WE
DON'T KNOW HOW WE'RE GOING TO
KEEP UP WITH THE RED ZONE A
HEARING FROM OUR SECURITY
OFFICERS ONE IS SILICON.
VALLEY THAT WAS SPOKEN NATIONAL
CONFERENCES CLEANING HI TECH
MULTI BILLION DOLLAR COMPANIES --
AND BEING A SECURITY OFFICER
THAT LIVING IN THEIR CARS.
WORKING FULL TIME.
AND NOT BEING ABLE TO AFFORD A
SPACE TO LIVE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS UNACCEPTABLE SO
YOU HAVE.
YOU HAVE ME HERE REPRESENTATION
OF OUR FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
MEMBERS AND ALSO SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF SCA YOU CALIFORNIA.
AT THE TIME.
TO ADDRESS THE HOUSING CRISIS.
IS NOW WE CAN NO LONGER WAY OUR
MEMBERS CAN A LONGER WAIT ARE
GOING TO BE HOLDEN EVERYONE
ACCOUNTABLE TO HAVE A TOUGH
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE NEED TO
HAVE IN THE STATE. TO MAKE SURE
THAT CALIFORNIANS ARMING
CALIFORNIANS THAT LOOK LIKE
SECURITIES LIKE JANITORS LIKE
HOME CARE WORKERS ARE PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES THAT WE CAN ALL HAVE A
SPACE.
AND CALL CONTINUE TO CALL THIS
OUR HOME AND THAT HOPEFULLY THE
HOME IS NOT OUR CARS HOPEFULLY
THE HOME IS NOT I'D IV OUTSIDE
OF OF A PARKING LOT WHERE I HAVE
NEWS WHERE I HAVE TO TAKE.
AND BORROW ELECTRICITY IN STATE
MAY AND C. HOMINID WAKE UP
TOMORROW SO I SEE THAT AND I'M
HERE.
PROUD OF THE WORK THAT I'M
SITTING MEMBER CHIU HAS DONE AND
HOPE THAT WE CAN WITH THE
CONVERSATION FOR IT.
THANK YOU.
YES.
MISTER NIAS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
SRT HAS OVER HALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL.
OF VERY PROUD TO BE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF OF A KEY PIECE OF THE
HOUSING PACKAGE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS DEBATING.
YESTERDAY WE WERE LOOKING AT
PRODUCTION BILL SB FIFTY WERE
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT BUT THAT
COULD NOT BE ARE ALL THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
PIECE.
A LOT OF OUR MEMBERS BOB WHEN
THEY GET A RAISE IT'S NOT GOING
TO THEIR POCKET IS NOT GOING TO
DISTRIBUTE THROUGHOUT THE
ECONOMY.
IT'S GOING TO ACTUALLY PAY FOR
THE RENT AND THE HIGH COST OF OF
HOUSING IN TODAY'S ECONOMY.
YES THEY ARE STEADILY WORKING --
BUT WITH WITH THE COST OF HEALTH
CARE RISE IN THE COST OF
TRANSPORTATION THE COST OF
LIVING IN GENERAL.
EVERYTHING IS GOING TO SOMEONE
ELSE AND NOT TO THEMSELVES.
WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF MOVEMENT
FROM OUR MEMBERS NOT ONLY -- IN
TERMS OF THE WORK AND AND AND
IT'S NATURAL FOR THEM TO WORK
AND AND AND TRAVEL ABOUT A
HUNDRED MILES TO GET TO A
CONSTRUCTION SITE.
BUT WHEN THEY HAVE TO MOVE FROM
THE URBAN CENTERS WHERE A LOT OF
THAT GROWTH IS TAKING PLACE INTO
THE CENTRAL VALLEY BECAUSE
THAT'S THE ONLY PLACE I CAN
AFFORD.
THAT EXTENDS THEIR COMMUTE TIME
SO MUCH MORE AND THAT IMPACTS
OUR QUALITY OF LIFE IN THE TIMES
WITH THEIR FAMILIES.
WHAT WE SEE HERE IS AN IMPORTANT
STEP TO BRIDGE THE DIVIDE
BETWEEN INCOME AND RENTAL PRICES
WELL AT THE SAME TIME SCALING UP
THE PRODUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING TO MEET THE NEEDS OF THE
WORKING CLASS?
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO WILL
ACHIEVE THIS BY CAPPING ANNUAL
RATE INCREASE AT A SUFFICIENT
LEVEL ABOVE THE CONSUMER PRICE
INDEX.
THE BILL SEEKS TO BALANCE THE
NEEDS OF RENTERS WITH THOSE A
PROPERTY OWNERS ENABLING A FAIR
RETURN SIMILAR TO OTHER BUSINESS
INVESTMENTS AND EXEMPTING UNITS
SUBJECT TO EXISTING RENT TO RENT
CONTROL PROTECTIONS.
DEED RESTRICTED IN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
WE BELIEVE THE FAR TOO MANY
WORKERS ARE BEING FORCED OUT OF
TO WORK TWO OR THREE JOBS AWAY
FROM THEIR FAMILIES AND
SUFFERING LONGER COMMUTES IN
ORDER TO ADD A FORTY EXCESSIVE
INCREASES.
AND RENTAL PAYMENT IN ORDER TO
AVOID BEING HOMELESS AND FOR
THOSE REASONS WE URGENTLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MISS THE D. IS -- I
NOW LEYVA WHEN ASKED IF THERE'S
ANY -- ANY MEMBER FROM THE
OPPOSITION THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY
.
BUSINESS CARLTON YES GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS DEBORAH CARLSON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION FIRST I WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL VERY MUCH FOR
LABORING OVER THIS VERY
DIFFICULT SITUATION I KNOW WE'RE
pALL SEARCHING FOR ANSWERS.
TO OUR HOUSING CRISIS YOU KNOW
IN OUR CONCERNS OF ALWAYS BEEN
TO MAKE SURE THAT WHATEVER WE DO
WE'RE NOT GOING TO MAKE.
A BAD SITUATION WORSE.
WE CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO SCARE
OFF DEVELOPMENT AND I KNOW AS
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER STATED IT
TAKES YEARS TO BUILD HOUSING AND
THAT'S SHAMEFUL IN CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE ONE DEVELOPER THAT IS NOW
TAKING HIM THIRTEEN YEARS. TO
GET TO THE TIME IN WHICH SHE
WILL AT LEAST BE ABLE TO START
CONSTRUCTION.
NO PROVIDING AN ADEQUATE SUPPLY
OF HOUSING WE ARGUE IS TRULY THE
ANSWER.
DESPITE THE FACT IT TAKES WAY
TOO LONG BUT IT IS THE WAY TO
PROTECT TENANTS BOTH EXISTING
TENANTS AND FUTURE TENANTS.
NOW WITH THAT SAID.
WE DON'T BELIEVE THAT OWNERS WHO
ARE TRYING TO DO THE RIGHT THING
BY THEIR TENANTS WOULD VIOLATE.
THE STANDARDS SET OUT.
IN THIS LEGISLATION.
HOWEVER OUR CONCERN IS NOT AS
MUCH ABOUT.
THIS CURRENT.
BILL BUT THE FUTURE TEMPTATION
AND DEMANDS OF THE LEGISLATURE
WILL FACE TO LOWER THE STANDARD.
MOST RENT CONTROL CITIES STARTED
OUT WITH THE STANDARD SIMILAR TO
THIS.
BUT TODAY WE HAVE 60% OF CPI IN
SAN FRANCISCO 65% OF CP I AM
BERKELEY AND 75% OF CP I IN
SANTA MONICA.
AS HOUSING COSTS CONTINUE TO
RISE THAT'S OBVIOUSLY A A HUGE
CONCERN.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT FEES FOR
EXAMPLE IN LOS ANGELES WENT UP
WITH RECYCLING OWNERS ARE FACING
A 3100% INCREASE IN IN RECYCLING
COSTS.
THEY CAN'T RECAPTURE THAT OF
COURSE.
OWNERS DON'T OR OWNERS AND
TENANTS TO TENNIS DON'T MOVE
UNDER THOSE SITUATIONS.
BUT WE ALSO DON'T WANT TO LET
CITIES AND COUNTIES OFF THE HOOK.
LACING BLAME OF COURSE ON THE
RENTAL HOUSING INDUSTRY IS AN
EASY ANSWER.
BUT PROVIDING PLACES FOR PEOPLE
TO LIVE IS THE REAL SOLUTION.
WE REALLY WOULD LIKE TO SEE A
LINK.
IN FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO TO
HOUSING PRODUCTION.
AND OF COURSE AS YOU KNOW ORGAN
RECENTLY IMPOSED A STATEWIDE
RENT CAP AT 7% PLUS THE CONSUMER
PRICE INDEX. FOR CALIFORNIA TO
PROVIDE A LOWER CAP CERTAINLY IS
QUESTIONABLE OF COURSE OUR COST
OF LIVING HERE.
LAND PRICES CONSTRUCTION AND
FEES ARE MUCH HIGHER.
CALIFORNIA IS THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD TWENTY FIVE
SECONDS FIRST IN THE UNITED
STATES ORGANISED TWENTY FIFTH.
WE NEED A REAL SOLUTION AND WE
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING ALL OF
OUR CONCERNS HERE TODAY THANK
YOU.
WE WE CAN HELLO GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
CREAM THREE CM HALF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS.
AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED C. R.
OPPOSES AB -- FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO WHICH PLACES A STATEWIDE CAP
ON THE AMOUNT THE RENTAL
PROPERTY OWNER MAY ANNUALLY
INCREASE RENT.
AS PREVIOUSLY NOTED IN THIS
HEARING -- ORGAN ENACTED SB SIX
AWAIT EARLIER THIS YEAR.
THAT LAW FEATURES A 7% PLUS CPI
CAP AS WELL AS A FIFTEEN YEAR
NEW CONSTRUCTION EXEMPTION.
BASED ON CONVERSATIONS SEE OURS
HAD WITH THE AUTHOR THE
ADMINISTRATION THE SPONSORS AND
STAFF SEE OUR WILL BE DISCUSSING
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO AT ITS
UPCOMING BUSINESS MEETINGS NEXT
WEEK.
DURING THESE MEETINGS SEE OUR
WILL EVALUATE THE BILL AND HAVE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL INPUT ON THE MEASURE.
SEE OUR LOOKS FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
LEGISLATURE AS A WHOLE AS IT
EXPLORES VARIOUS PUBLIC POLICY
OPTIONS THAT SEEK TO ADDRESS
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING CRISIS
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF BE BEFORE
YOU START -- I THE CHAIRMAN THE
THE OPPOSITION HAS A HAS A
REQUEST WHERE -- IN IN THEIR
COLLECTIVE TEN MINUTES -- THEY
WOULD LIKE TO SPLIT IT.
INTO AMONG FOUR SPEAKERS INSTEAD
OF THREE IS THAT OKAY WITH YOU
THAT'S FINE WITH ME OKAY -- WE
NEEDS OF THE GERMAN ONLY USE THE
TWO MINUTES SO YOU HAVE AN EXTRA
MINUTE HERE.
A YOU SO WITH.
GOOD AND USED USE YOUR THREE
MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ADAM WRIGLEY ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE IN OPPOSITION.
WE ALL AGREE CALIFORNIA IS IN
THE MIDST OF A SEVERE HOUSING
CRISIS THE STATE WIDE FAILURE TO
KEEP UP WITH NEW DEMAND FOR
HOUSING.
EVEN THROUGH RAPID ECONOMIC
GROWTH AND NOW HISTORIC LOW
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES.
HAS RESULTED IN A SEVERE
SHORTAGE OF AVAIL HOUSING UNITS
AND CORRESPONDINGLY.
RAPIDLY RISING HOUSING AND
RENTAL COSTS.
WHILE MANY FACTORS HAVE A ROLE
IN DRIVING CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING
HIGH HOUSING COSTS THE MOST
IMPORTANT AND SIGNIFICANT FACTOR
IS A SHORTAGE OF HOUSING.
THIS IS NOT MY PERSONAL OPINION
THIS IS THE CONCLUSION FROM A
SUBSTANTIAL BODY OF ECONOMIC
RESEARCH STUDYING HOUSING MARKET
DATA.
AS WELL AS THE CONCLUSION YEAR
AFTER YEAR FROM CALIFORNIA'S
NONPARTISAN FISCAL POLICY
ADVISER THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE.
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO DOES
EXACTLY OPPOSITE OF WHAT LA --
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE THE BILL
DISINCENTIVE EYES IS DESPERATELY
NEEDED NEW HOUSING BY FAILING TO
INCLUDE ANY EXEMPTIONS FOR NEW
CONSTRUCTION.
RENT CAPS ON NEW CONSTRUCTION
SIMPLY DO NOT PENCIL OUT.
EVEN IN OREGON'S RECENTLY PASSED
RENT CAP LAW IT INCLUDES AN
EXEMPTION FOR NEW CONSTRUCTION.
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO ALSO
CHERRY PICKS FROM THE CASA
COMPAQ LEAVING OUT CRUCIAL
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT BALANCE A
RENT CAP WITH THE REALITIES OF
RISING COSTS ON LANDLORDS.
A PASS THROUGH PROVISION WHICH
WAS INCLUDED IN THE CASA COMPAQ
RECOMMENDATION WOULD ALLOW
INCREASES IN WATER SEWER WASTE
WATER TRASH ELECTRIC.
AND GAS AS WELL AS COST OF
CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS THAT ARE
NECESSARY TO MAINTAIN THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY.
OF UNITS.
ON TO THEIR TENANTS.
THE CASA COMPAQ ALSO RECOMMENDS
A SUNSET PROVISION TO PROVIDE
THE LEGISLATURE WITH A SET TIME
FRAME TO REVISIT THE EFFICACY OF
THIS NEW POLICY.
WE OPPOSE AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
NOT BECAUSE WE DISAGREE WITH THE
AUTHOR'S INTENTION OF PROVIDING
HOUSING RELIEF TO CALIFORNIANS
ACROSS THE STATE.
WE SHARE THAT GOAL.
BUT BECAUSE THIS BILL WILL
COMPOUND CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING
HOUSING CRISIS BY MAKING THE
LONG TERM AND MOST IMPORTANT
SOLUTION ACCORDING TO EMPIRICAL
DATA BUILDING MORE SUPPLY.
EVEN HARDER FOR THAT WE ARE TO
KNOW ABOUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS IS A
THIS BILL YOU HAVE ABOUT TWO
MINUTES.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR COMEDY ME --
WARNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS KATE
FELL ON EHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS ROUNDTABLE AND THE
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION.
REPRESENTS MORE THAN TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND MEMBERS IN OVER HALF A
MILLION UNITS IN THE STATE WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL IN ITS
CURRENT FORM BUT WE DO
APPRECIATE THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE STAFFS ATTENTION TO
THIS MATTER.
AND SHOULD THE BILL MOVE OR LOOK
FOR TO CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS
THANK YOU.
SIR THANK YOU MISSPELLED AND OF
BRICKS DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
OR YOU OR YOUR DAUGHTER WOULD
DIE WITHIN THIS BACK TO YOU WE
CAN WE CAN GO TO PUBLIC COMMENTS
AND WE CAN UP DISCUSSION NOW OR
WAIT UNTIL PUBLIC COMIDAS
OVERNIGHT DISCUSSION THE AND
IT'S UP [inaudible]
TO AS OKAY SOUNDS LIKE A ONE
STEP DISCUSSION AFTERWARDS SO IF
THAT'S THE CASE THAT THAT TIME
I'M GONNA COME BACK TO THE
DIGEST ALL PRESENT A REPUBLICAN
WHICH IS A GERMAN PLEASE COME
BACK TO A THREE SEAT
.
THIS TIME WE WILL START GENERAL
PUBLIC COMMENTS AS I MENTIONED --
PEOPLE WILL BE ABLE -- TO TO
LINE UP.
AND WE'RE GONNA ASK EVERYONE
AGAIN. TO STATE YOUR NAME. ONE
AFFILIATION AND WHETHER YOU
SUPPORTER POSE A BILL STARTING
WITH THE FIRST.
MR CHEN MEMBERS CAITLIN VEGA FOR
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
I ANYA LAWLER WITH THE WESTERN
CENTER AMMAN POVERTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PAT RAN
WITH THEIR AND READING
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA RENTAL
HOUSING ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
MAIN A YOUNG I'M WITH.
BAY AREA HOMEOWNERS NETWORK.
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI MY NAME IS AMBROSE YOUR
KERETA I REMEMBER IT ICE -- THEY
SAY YES TO THE A. B. THIRTY SIX
AND YESTERDAY.
AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO CECILIA
INCOME FROM SAN FRANCISCO NO ON
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO ISAAC CARES
WITH THE ALLIANCE OF
CALIFORNIA'S OUR COMMUNITY
EMPOWERMENT STRONG SUPPORT A. B.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO AND A. B..
THIRTY SIX MY NAME'S K<c.cyan> WAR</c>
FROM SEVEN CISCO I COME HERE TO
SAY NO.
ON A. B. ONE FOR A TOOL.
MY NAME IS TINA HOME ROLE I AM
FROM SOME IS IS A CALL I JUST
WANT TO THE STATE THE OLD ONE AB.
ONE FOUR EIGHT TWO INCH.
MY NAME IS THE BIG CHAU.
AGUNTHER BUT ON THE SEVENTH A
SICKLE.
AND ALL A. B..
ONE FOUR EIGHT TWO MY NAME IS
THERE A SONG COMING FROM SEVEN
CISCO.
NO AB ONE FOUR EIGHT TWO THANK
YOU -- GLOBALLY I COME FROM SAN
FRANCISCO.
NO ON A. B. ONE FALL
[inaudible]
EIGHTY TWO HI.
SOME OF THE CITY.
BEING IN THE AT THE END
[inaudible]
I THANK.
I'M CAL IN FOR ME SEVEN THE
CISCO.
NOT.
ONE YEAH I'M CAN LEARNING FROM
SERVICES CALL NOW ON EIGHT B..
FOURTEEN MULLIN SOIL FROM
SERVICES HOLE I'LL POST
[inaudible]
AP. FOURTEEN FIFTY TWO MY NAME
IS HOW WE ARE SENTIMENTAL COMING
FROM SACRAMENTO -- ACE MEMBERS
AND GUESTS ON FOURTEEN EIGHTY TO
SEIZE APPOINTED.
MY NAME IS AMBER GONZALEZ AGAIN.
FOR LOS ANGELES A MEMBER OR NAY
SAYING YES I SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS BILL WONG FROM SAN
FRANCISCO.
IN A VOTE ON B..
ONE FOUR EIGHT TWO MY NAME IS
JEAN ALONG WITH BUT A HOUSING MY
NAME IS THE HIGHLAND COME FROM
SAN FRANCISCO.
LOW AB.
ONE FOUR EIGHT TWO HI.
MY NAME IS SAM KHôNG ROOM COME
FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
I OPPOSE SB.
ONE FORTY TWO MY NAME DISAPPEAR
YOU WON'T I FOR NUMBER OF SAN
FRANCISCO.
LOW A. B.. FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
MY NAME IS MICHAEL SALAS.
I AM LEAVING A LOCAL CALIFORNIA
IS IN MY FAVORITE VOTER WAS.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO ALSO I NEED
TO AB.
TWENTY SIX LIVES ISRAEL UP IS
ACE OAKLAND YES FOURTEEN A TWO
AND A. B. THIRTY SIX THE RENT IS
TOO HIGH.
ALI OUT PHELPS OAKLAND ACE YES I
AB THIRTY SIX AND YES ON AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO MY NAME IS
ALAN LEE CHILD LAYING ON MY SON
FROM SAN FRANCISCO I AM
REPRESENTING ALLEN LEECH ALFA
MAY OUR SPA SAN FRANCISCO.
WE ARE FROM ELEVENTH DISTRICT WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL VALLEY MUCH
IT'S MISSING LEASE IT'S
MISLEADING THE PUBLIC.
AB CARMONA PROUD CO SPONSOR AND
STRONG SUPPORTER OF AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO AND A. B..
THIRTY SIX HI MY NAME IS KERRY
COUNTY HAVE NO AFFILIATION HI
OPPOSE.
BILL AB.
ONE FOUR EIGHT TWO MIKE PARKER
RICHMOND PROGRESSIVE ALLIANCE
STRONG SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
ANNA GARCIA WITH ACE IN OAKLAND
I STRONG SUPPORT FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO AND A. B..
THIRTY SIX I'M WILLIAM CASEY
WITH ACE RICHMOND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB. FOURTEEN EIGHTY TO
AB.
THIRTY SIX GOOD MORNING ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS MY NAME IS RUSS SCHOOL
K. YOUNG YOUNG REPRESENTING OF
RICHMOND COUNCIL MEMBERS EDUARDO
MARTINEZ AND YOU'VE AKA BECKLES.
YES ON AB FOURTEEN A TWO ALSO WE
NEED AB THIRTY SIX THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS KATHLEEN GREEN.
FROM CONCORD CALIFORNIA
REPRESENT ACE.
AND A REVOLUTION CONTRA COSTA WE
NEED TO YES UNFORTUNATE TO AN AB.
FIFTY SIX THIRTY SIX SORRY.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS NOT MY NAME IS MELVIN
WILLIS I'M SPEAKING AS AN
INDIVIDUAL RICHMOND CITY COUNCIL
MEMBER I STRONGLY SUPPORT
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO AND A. B..
THIRTY SIX HI MY NAME NEW SO
SILLY ABOUT IT BECAUSE I KNEW
SUPPORT THE A. B. ONE FOUR
EIGHTY TWO AND AB THIRTY SO YOU
FOR RENT CONTROL FOR OUT
CALIFORNIA.
HI MY NAME IS LAURA HUMANNESS
AND I'VE LIVED HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND I SUPPORT AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO AND MAYBE.
THIRTY SIX HUNDRED LINES OF THE
THIRTY ONE YEAR HOMEOWNER FROM
OAKLAND CALIFORNIA.
AND A MEMBER ABOUT THE MADE A
TRANS UNION.
ONE NINETY TWO AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB THIRTY SIX AND AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO GOOD MORNING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'M MICHAEL
CHOW FROM SAN FRANCISCO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS BUT
THREE CELL YEAH I COME FROM BAY
POINT.
I'M OF A SLIMMER IN EYES SO I IS
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB THIRTY SIX
AND MAY BE.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO FROM THE V.
F. IN THE MIDDLE BLANCA COMING
UP FOR YOU AVE.
THE AND THEY SAY.
MY NAME IS GRACE MARTINEZ I AM
FROM SAN FRANCISCO I'M WITH
CALIFORNIA ACE I SUPPORT AB
THIRTY SIX AND AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO CAN WE PUT
DOWN.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE MY NAME IS
OUT BY BRIAN HURT ME BON BON I'M
WITH THE COMMUNITY GROUP.
EIGHT OUT HEY AND YOU KNOW I'M
HERE TO SUPPORT FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
SINCE AUGUST HOMELESS ANGELA IS
AND YES -- FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
AND THIRTY SIX YOUR VOICE IS
ISN'T ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY NAME
IS JOSEPH WAS THE THIRD I'M A
FROM RICHMOND CALIFORNIA I'M AN
OPEN CALIFORNIA RUNNER.
I SUPPORT AB THIRTY SIX AND A
BEFORE DALY.
TO MY NAME IS MAY I'M FROM SAN
FRANCISCO -- NO ON A. B..
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS -- I'M NOT A HOLE IN THE
FUNDS AND THE CISCO.
I'M STRONGLY OPPOSE AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO NO A. B..
HI MY NAME IS A NEED SEVENTIES
COAL NO ON AB. FORTY EIGHTY TWO
FOR NEARLY MIGUEL TROUBLE YEAH
IN SUPPORT OF THE FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO AND SB.
THIRTY SIX GOOD MORNING DAVID
SHARPLES OF THE COMMUNITY GROUP
ACE AND A RESIDENT OF RICHMOND
CALIFORNIA
WHAT IS MEANT THAT
CAST MOSTLY A KEY PINEAPPLE YET
LIBERAL PLACE THAT HAVE A DRINK
THEY SAY SABIC THAT THOUGH SUCH
IT THEY SAY.
LOS.
MY NAME IS ELLEN MARI OAKLAND
ACE.
WORKERS UNITED WILL NEVER BE
DEFEATED SUPPORTING AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO AND A. B..
THIRTY SIX FRANCISCO TAURUS
PITTSBURG CALIFORNIA A MEMBER OF
BASS.
SUPPORT AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
AND THIRTY SIX I'M THREE OF US
WITH EIGHTIES IN RICH MAN AND I
SUPPORT. EIGHTEEN FOR FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO AND THE SB.
THIRTY SIX HELLO MY NAME IS
MYRON ZACHARY TAYLOR ON FROM SAN
DIEGO CALIFORNIA I REPRESENT ACE
AND THE HOMELESS ON THE STREETS
OF SAN DIEGO SUPPORTING.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO HELLO MY
NAME IS MADDIE ABLE MAN THANK
THEM FROM LOS ANGELES ACE MEMBER.
YES THEY MAY BE.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY EIGHTY TWO EIGHT
APART AB.
THIRTY SIX HI MY NAME IS SILVA
RODRIGUEZ AND I'M SUPPORT WELL
ONE FOURTEEN FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
AND AB.
THIRTY SIX GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS SAM RANDOM MAYES AYE I'M WITH
PUSH POMONA UNITED FOR STABLE
HOUSING.
I'M ALSO WITH THE P. O. C.
CENTER WHICH IS POMONA ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY CENTER AND I'M ALSO
A MEMBER OF ACE AND I'M HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
OF AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO AND
YOU LAYS THE REALLY NEED TO PAY
ATTENTION TO A. B..
THIRTY SIX GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS CHRISTINA LIVING ST I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
COMMUNITY GROUP ACE AND WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
SIX AND AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO HI GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS MAHDI
ACCENTURE'S I AM FROM SAN DIEGO
AND A REPRESENTATIVE OF EIGHTH.
ALSO A VOLUNTEER FOR THE YMCA
YOUTH PROGRAM THE CDC AND THE
TOYS FOR TOTS FOUNDATION.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT.
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO WHEN I
ALSO STRONGLY SUPPORT AB. THIRTY
SIX ONE OF THE OTHER MEN NUMBERS
ON HELENA JIMENEZ BINGO THE LOS
ANGELES.
YOUR AVE THREE INTO A SAFE HE
AVE COUPLE CHILDREN BY THOSE
NOTHING -- THE NUMBER IS MONEY
ALSO TO EVEN WITH THE LOS
ANGELES.
YEAH POUR YOUR LOVE IT A COUPLE
SUCH A BY THOSE YEAH I HAVE IT
PRETTY TO THINK.
HELLO MY NAME IS NEVER IN I
SUPPORT ONE FOUR EIGHT TWO AND
THIRTY SIX MY NAME.
MY NAME IS CHRIS DABBLE.
MY NAME IS GUSTAVO I SUPPORT.
ONE FOUR A TWO AND A. B..
THIRTY SIX THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS GLORIA
CORTES AND I'M FROM LA DISTRICT
ELSA ACE MEMER IN HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY SIX AND AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANKS.
SYLVIA OF IN A GUY'S VAN NUYS
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO SPEAKING FOR
ALL THE HOMEOWNERS WHO LOST
THEIR HOME AFTER DAUGHTER ACT.
I SUPPORT AB THIRTY SIX AND
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO AT THIS TIME
I WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU WHO
ARE HERE THE AUDIENCE AS YOU
KNOW WE HAVE MANY.
MANY EQUIVALENT ROOMS THAT WE
NEED TO GET THROUGH PUBLIC
COMMENT SO I'M GOING TO ASK
EVERYONE WHO'S SITTING HERE IF
YOU COULD PLEASE.
HAD OUT SO THAT WE CAN REFILL
THE SEATS AND GO OVER AGAIN
BECAUSE OTHERWISE WE JUST DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH ROOM TO CIRCULATE IT
OUT BUT I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE
FOR COMING.
AND WE WILL OBVIOUSLY ALL -- BE
IN TOUCH.
AND IF THANK YOU FOR EVERYONE
COULD PLEASE LEAVE AS QUICKLY
AND AS QUIETLY AS YOU CAN AND
THEN WE'RE GONNA ASK A NEW ROOM
FULL OF FOLKS TO COME IN.
THANK YOU
.
MY NAME IS DAVID CHIU ON THE
CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY ON THE COMMITTEE I
WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU FOR
COMING TO TODAY'S HEARING.
THE HEARING HAS ALREADY
COMMENCED AS YOU KNOW -- WE HAVE
ALREADY HEARD FROM WITNESSES ON
BOTH SIDES BUT WHAT WE WERE
DOING AT THIS TIME HIS WERE
TAKING PUBLIC COMMENTS OF COURSE
WE ALL WISH WITH A MUCH LARGER.
ASSEMBLY ROOM BUT WE DON'T UP
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN PUBLIC
COMMENTS AND WE'VE ALREADY HEARD
FROM THE FIRST FIFTY MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC.
IS WE'RE GONNA ASK EACH OF YOU
WHO WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS YOUR
OPINION TO EXPRESS.
IT IN THE WAY THAT WE DO IN
HEARINGS WITH PEOPLE OF THIS
MANY WITH WITH THIS MANY
INDIVIDUALS.
EVERYONE WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THE FOLLOWING
TO STATE YOUR NAME. ONE
AFFILIATION AND WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THIS BILL AND
I SHOULD MENTION THERE WERE TWO
BILLS ON TODAY'S COUNTER BUT AB
THIRTY SIX HAS BEEN PULLED AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR.
BACK TO THE ASSEMBLY RULES
COMMITTEE SO ALL THAT IS IN
FRONT y
EIGHTY TWO I'M GONNA GIVE AN
EXAMPLE OF HOW YOU DO PUBLIC
COMMENT.
WHICH JUST YOU'LL STEP UP TO
THAT MICROPHONE.
AND YOU'LL SAY.
MY NAME IS DAVID CHIU I'M FROM
SAN FRANCISCO AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
AND WE ARE ASKING EVERYONE TO
LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO THAT
BECAUSE IF YOU DON'T WE'RE GONNA
BE HERE FOREVER AND WE ARE
TREATING EVERYONE EQUALLY AND SO
HELP EVERYONE CAN UNDERSTAND AND
APPRECIATE THAT SO WITH THAT.
THE OTHER THING I'M GONNA SAY IS
A PLEASE DO NOT WAVE SIGNS.
THAT'S AGAINST THE RULES OF THIS
ASSEMBLY BECAUSE IT BLOCKS OF
USE OF INDIVIDUALS BEHIND YOU.
AND AGAIN I HOPE IT GOES WITHOUT
SAYING BUT WE ASKING OR ASKING
EVERYONE TO BE COURTEOUS. TO NOT
EXPRESS A PERSPECTIVE IF YOU'RE
NOT AT THE MICROPHONE IF YOU
REALLY NEED TO YOU CAN USE YOUR
JAZZ HANDS AS A WAY TO EXPRESS
SILENCE SUPPORT SO WITH THAT.
I WANT TO THANK THE SERGEANTS
FOR WHAT THEY'RE DOING TO
CONVENE AND IF YOU COULD START
PUBLIC COMMENT AGAIN THANK YOU
[inaudible]
PLEASE MA'AM.
YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION WHAT
DO YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE.
AT THE LEAST CITY [inaudible]
LOW.
AB ONE FOR A TOLL PERFECT THANK
YOU.
MY NAME IS TODAY YOU'LL YEAH
MELISSA.
FROM THE ISSUE THE I SEE IN DOLE
AB ONE FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
HI MY NAME IS THERESA DO GAY I'M
THOSE IS THAT THE SECOND
DIRECTOR FROM SAN FRANCISCO
COMMITTEE HIM PALM IN CENTER.
I WE ALL OPPOSE ONE FOUR OUT
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK LOS.
MY NAME IS DOING MAY FROM L.
WORLD.
AYE OPPOSED FORTY AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO MY NAME IS
RAMONA CHIANG I COME FROM
OAKLAND I REPRESENT THE RENTAL
HOUSING ASSOCIATION AND ALSO THE
ASIAN REAL ESTATE ASSOCIATION OF
THE EAST BAY.
WE OPPOSE AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY ONE
AND FOURTEEN THIRTY EIGHTY TWO
HI MY NAME IS TO ME HOLE.
I COME TO LOOK US AND THEN SIXTY
CALL UNTIL EIGHT P.. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO MY DAY IS ON THE
PHONE -- SUPPLEMENTAL.
NO. FORTY EIGHTY TWO MY NAME YOU
SEE LEVY WHAT SORROW.
I AM FULLER IN SAN FRANCISCO A.
B..
A. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT TO
LOW.
MY NAME IS JUDY FROM SEVEN CISCO.
LOW AB.
FORTY EIGHTY TWO MY NAME IS NONI
REGION I'M PRESIDENT OF THE
SMALL PROPERTY OWNERS OF SAN
FRANCISCO PLEASE VOTE NO ON THIS
HOUSING KILLER BILL THANK YOU.
RYAN WAGNER REAL ESTATE BROKER
HERE IN SACRAMENTO STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO PATRICK
WAGNER LANDLORDS SACRAMENTO NO.
THREE SO WAGNER MULTI FAMILY
SACRAMENTO NO ONE AB.
ONE FORTY TWO ROBERTO HATCH
SANTA CLARA COUNTY KNOWN.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO PETER HOLDEN
SMALL PROPERTY OWNERS HERE CISCO
NO ON FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THIS
IS THE MEDICINE COME FROM OUR
SERVICE TO SCHOOL NO ON AB
[inaudible]
ONE FOR THE TWO THIS IS
STEPHANIE FROM SAN FRANCISCO --
RESIDENTIAL PROPERTY OWNERS.
OPPOSE A. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
THANK YOU.
IS MY LEAH I'M FROM SACRAMENTO.
OPPOSE AB FORTY EIGHTY TWO THANK
YOU.
WE HAVE AN FROM SAN FRANCISCO
STRONGLY AGAINST FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS TURNED DOWN FROM SAN
FRANCISCO I SAY NO ON A PRETTY.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO MY NAME IS
JIM TO GO.
THE I DON'T WANT TO BE. FOR THE
NAKED [inaudible]
TWO NO.
MY NAME IS CHEN KHôNG I'M FROM
FROM THE FISCAL AYE OPPOSED.
TO AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK.
MY NAME IS A ANGELA CHAMP FROM A
SAN FRANCISCO I'M A STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
A. B..
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO MY NAME IS.
DAN WARM I AM FROM SAN FRANCISCO
AYE OPPOSED.
A. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY TOOL.
MY NAME IS ASSEMBLYMAN IN AS
CALM THE SAN FRANCISCO.
AT A PARTY YEAH A. B..
FORTY EIGHT TO MY NAME'S IT WHEN
YOU'RE IN -- FROM SAN FRANCISCO --
YOU THE OPALS A. B..
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO MY NAME IS
JANET SO.
I'M FORUM SUMMONSES TO GO NO
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TOOL.
MY NAME IS EMMA.
I AM FROM SERVICES A CALL PLEASE
SEE.
LOW.
A. B.. FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK
YOU.
I FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
I SEE NO.
FULL. FOURTEEN EIGHTEN TO HI AM
PALM SOME VINES THIS GOAL.
NO ON AB FOURTEEN EIGHTEEN TOLL.
HI MY NAME IS YOU IAN -- FOR
SOME AND CISCO PLEASE LOW ON FOR
OF EIGHTY BE FORTY IN -- EIGHTY
TWO CHOI PAUL FROM SEVEN CISCO.
HELLO.
AB.
FOURTEEN FIFTY TWO THANK.
MY NAME IS SUSAN GEL FROM SAN
FRANCISCO NO ON A. B..
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO MY NAME IS
BETTY G. I AM FROM SOME AS HE'S
TOLD I AT SHE WAS.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO MY NAME IS
JUST LOW.
I AM COME FROM SAID MRS SCHOOL
KNOLL ON FOURTEEN FORTY EIGHT I
AM GLORIA YE I'M FROM SAN
FRANCISCO I STRONGLY OBJECT.
A. B..
ONE FOUR EIGHTY TWO MY NAME IS
WINNIE FORM -- FORMS A CIRCUS.
A SIMPLICITY I STRONGLY SAY NO
ON A. B..
ONE FOUR EIGHTY TWO FIND MCN I
COME FROM SAN FRANCISCO -- NO.
AB [inaudible]
THIRTY SIX AB. ONE FOURTEEN
EIGHTY ONE ONE FORTY EIGHTY TWO
WHICH IS ONE OF MY PEOPLE TODAY
WERE ONLY CONSIDERING AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU
[inaudible]
SERVICES GO.
ED LOW.
EIGHTY FOUR ONE FOUR EIGHT TWO
MY NAME IS AWAKE NINE TEN I'M
FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
NO A. B..
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO HI MY NAME'S
LINDA CALL FROM SOME THIS IS
DAHLE AYE STAYED IN THE OLD ONE
EIGHT BE.
FORTY EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU.
BECKY LEAVE FROM SAN FRANCISCO
PLEASE VOTE NO ON AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S TEAM -- I'M FROM
SAN FRANCISCO I WILL.
KNOW ALL A. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO THANK YOU.
MY NAME GENE THE LAW OF FUNDS.
I'M FROM SOME A CISCO LOW ON AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO MY NAME IS A
WE NEED THEM.
I'M KNOLL.
ON A. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY TOLL.
MY NAME A TEAM CHAIR I SUMS
EMERGENCY CO.
OP.
I POLICY.
I AM ONE FOUR EIGHTY TOLL.
MY NAME IS IN THE FOR SOME A
CISCO PLEASE LOW ON A. B..
FOURTEEN IF YOU.
TO HELLO BUT I HOPE MY NAY YOU
SEE IT JESSE.
TO THE ISLAND.
SAN FRANCISCO NO A B. ONE FOR A
TOOL.
MY NAME IS SCOTT SHANE FROM
DANVILLE CALIFORNIA.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B..
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO MY NAME IS
LILLY WONG FROM SAN FRANCISCO
I'M OPPOSE.
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK.
MY NAME IS JIM YEN I'M FROM
OAKLAND.
VOTE NO ON A. B. FORTY EIGHTY
TWO THANK YOU.
GINGER HIT SKI PRIVATE FOR
PROFIT MULTI FAMILY RENTER
RENTAL OWNER AND I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT BOTH OF THE ITEMS THAT
WERE ON THE AGENDA TODAY.
HI MY NAME IS SYLVIA KERR LETTO
I'M FROM SAN FRANCISCO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO GOOD MORNING --
MY NAME IS STEVEN SHANE I'M FROM.
SAN FRANCISCO OR SENIOR I
STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B..
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO AND I HOPE
YOU WILL CONSIDER TO VOTE
AGAINST IT.
HI MY NAME IS A TONY LONG I'M
FROM -- SOME A CISCO I'M VERY
STRONG.
OBJECT OPPOSE AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO MY NAME IS
SHIRLEY CHAN I'M FROM SAN
FRANCISCO AND ALSO REPRESENT MY
FAMILY MEMBER AND COWORKERS CD'S
UP SEMESTER COAL.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS J. TRUMP I WOULD
PRESENT MY FAMILY MY MOM'S.
EIGHTY SIX I 100% OPPOSE AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO HI I'M MINDY
KIRSCHNER FROM SAN FRANCISCO
WITH THE SAN FRANCISCO APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION ON THE SMALL
PROPERTY OWNERS OF SAN FRANCISCO.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS.
PERHAPS WELL INTENTIONED BUT ILL
CONCEIVED BILL THANK YOU.
I'M LINDA -- CLOSE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO AND I OPPOSE THE
ASSEMBLY BILL.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO HI MARSHALL
FONG FOR SOME CISCO.
AND I POSE -- PITTING BROTHER
GOES BROTHER IS THEREFORE NO ON
FOURTEEN EIGHT TWO MY NAME MAKE
WALK I AM PHAM SAYS SICKLE.
MY FAMILY A KNIFE FIGHT PEOPLE
THEY SAY NO ALL ALONG HE P..
FORTY EIGHTY TOLL.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ALBERT YANG AND I
REPRESENT -- I'M FROM SAN
FRANCISCO REPRESENTING MY
FAMILIES AND MY FRIENDS.
AND I AM OPPOSED A. B. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO BECAUSE A ONE SOFT A
PROBLEM AND TO MAKE DEVOID OF
THE WORKERS.
MY NAME IS GO GO WAR I AM THE
BOARD OF DIRECTOR OF CHINESE
RULE SAY ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS --
SMALL PROPERTY OWNER AND ALSO --
REAL ESTATE BROKER OWNER IN SAN
FRANCISCO I STRONGLY OPPOSE A.
B. ONE FOUR A TWO AND A NEED
RENT CONTROL LAW PLEASE.
MY NAME HAVE BEEN PAYING.
ON WIDESPREAD SO NO TO PAY THE
HOUSE POLICY.
IN I LIVE IN THE AREA.
I'M A SOLE OPPOSE. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE EVERYONE FOR COMING
TO PROVIDE YOUR PUBLIC COMMENTS --
WE'RE GONNA ASK HIM TO DO IS
PLEASE LEAVE AS EXPEDITIOUSLY AS
YOU CAN SO THAT WE CAN BRING
ANOTHER ROOM FULL OF THE PUBLIC
HERE THANK YOU FOR COMING
COMMITTEE. FOR EVERYONE TO STATE
ONLY YOUR NAME ONE AFFILIATION
AND WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE THIS BILL AB FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO AND I WILL SAY.
AB THIRTY SIX WHICH WAS EARLIER
ON THE AGENDA OUT WAS PULLED.
LAST NIGHT AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR BACK TO THE ASSEMBLY
RULES COMMITTEE SO WE ONLY HAVE
ONE ITEM IN FRONT OF US AND THAT
IS A BE.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO SO WHAT WE
WHAT -- AS OTHERS HAVE BEEN
DOING -- WE'RE ASKING YOU TO DO
THE FOLLOWING TO SAY NAME
AFFILIATION WHAT DO YOU SUPPORT
OR OPPOSE LIKE THIS.
MY NAME IS DAVID CHIU I'M FROM
SAN FRANCISCO AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
SECONDLY.
WE HAVE A RULE AGAINST WAVING OF
SIGNS BECAUSE IT IMPEDES THE
ABILITY OF PEOPLE WHO SIT BEHIND
YOU TO SEE.
I AND OF COURSE WE'RE ASKING
EVERYONE TO BE RESPECTFUL AND
COURTEOUS OF EVERYONE IN THIS
ROOM.
SO WITH THAT -- LET'S HEAR FROM
THE FIRST MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC.
HI MY NAME'S SISTERLY I AM FROM
THE SENATE INITIAL.
ADONAL AB. FOURTEEN EIGHTY TOOL
THANK YOU PERFECT [inaudible]
MY LIAM.
SEN TOM RULE.
I AM COME PHONES A LITTLE
[inaudible]
NO. FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK
YOU GRAYSON.
HI MARLENE TRêN.
RESIDENT OF SERVICES GOAL SMALL
PROPERTY OWNER I ALSO OPPOSED A
ASSEMBLY BILL.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU
MISTER [inaudible]
TRANSLATE.
FOR TERMS OF IDEA WHAT VEHICLE
OKAY OKAY IF SHE CAN THE
DOCTRINES.
OKAY.
I MY NAME IS SIMILARLY TILE.
I'M FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
AND LOW ON AP FORTY AND EIGHTY
TOLL.
MY NAME IS COLLEEN DAHLE AYE
FROM SEND THIS IS CALLED.
THE WHOLE.
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TOLL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S YOU WEARING.
I AM FROM SACRAMENTO -- ON A. B..
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO MY NAME.
TôI FONG.
WELL.
SOMEONE GET TO GO.
AB [inaudible] ONE ONE EIGHT TWO
POTENTIALLY FOR MY NAME
SHOULDN'T RESISTANT LAW.
FORMS OF RESEARCH SOBRE TO
SCHOOL.
I'LL POST.
AB [inaudible]
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KAREN CAM FROM.
CALIFORNIA ALKYL -- I'M POLLS.
A. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK
YOU.
MY DAD DAD THE DOGS THROUGH A
COUPLE OF SACRAMENTO I SHOULD
KNOW A. B. FOR KIDS AGED.
TWO MY NAME IS PULLING LAKE
CONSTANCE SO I COME FROM
SACRAMENTO I COME AND SAY NO ON
A. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK
YOU.
I AM THOUSAND CHOI I COMPANIES
SOUNDS AGO.
THE POST AB. ONE FOR A LITTLE.
I'M LATE FUNDS SORRY.
I COMFORT SOME PHYSICAL.
I LOW FALL AB ONE FALL A TWO
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS EVA FROM.
TIME VENTRICLE I I'M LOS -- A.
B. [inaudible]
ONE FOUR EIGHT TWO THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S SIMON COME FROM ELKO.
LOW A. P..
FOURTEEN TO MY NAY KING Là TERM.
I IN.
SILENCE OF HELLO AP ONE FOUR AND
THE WHOLE.
MY NAME IS TO END THE WAR I CAME
FROM CITY ANGEL.
NO AND AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO MY NAME IS
MAY TENTH I AM FOR ON THE SEVEN
SIXTY GO -- LOW ON EIGHTY
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO MY NAME IS
THE ONE FROM SAN FRANCISCO PEACE
NO AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO MY NAME IS A
NEED TO CHEN COME FROM DALY CITY.
LOW ON A. B.. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO NAY THEN DURHAM HAMMER.
EAST BAY RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION DIRECTOR
[inaudible]
OPPOSE.
MY NAME IS.
WHICH ONLY -- TO FORM OAKLAND.
AND ON FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO MY
NAME IS NY YING I'M FROM OKAY
CITY.
NO EIGHT B. [inaudible]
ONE FOUR EIGHT TWO THANK YOU.
MY NAME USES WHEN.
I'M FOR OUR OWN SO -- AND FOR
SOMEHOW MOST.
EIGHTY AB HOUSES I PASSED THE AB.
ONE FORTY EIGHT TO GOOD MORNING%
MY NAME IS JACQUELINE JACOBS ON
THE BOARD MEMBER THE EAST BAY
RENTAL HOUSING ASSOCIATION AYE
OPPOSED BY A. B..
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO MY LAZY SON
CHEN FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
I OPPOSE AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO MY NAME IS
JACK VIEW.
HI I AM FROM SACRAMENTO.
I A POST.
THE TOOL.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO MY NAM
EIGHTY CM TEN WALL I HAVE FULL --
ALAMEDA.
AND ALL.
ONE AB.
ONE FOUR EIGHT TWO MY NAME IS A
THAT'S HOW FROM RICHMOND.
NO ON A. B..
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO READ
ROBERTSON VALLEJO OPPOSE.
I LIKE SCHOOL FROM FRANCISCO SAY
NO.
STRENUOUS RUN A D. FROM DOWN
WILL KNOW ON A. B. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THANK.
STANLEY CHAN FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
WE OPPOSE A. B..
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO MY NAME IS
CARI FROM SERVICES GOAL THE
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO MY NAME'S A
CAR A A COME FROMSOME CISCO NO
A. B.. FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO MY
NAME THE TREE IS THAT FROM SAN
FRANCISCO DAHLE A. B.. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO MY NAME IS BLAINE
CARTER I'M A I'M FROM CONCORD
CALIFORNIA REPRESENT MYSELF AS A
SMALL BUSINESS OWNER OF A SINGLE
UNIT.
AND I OPPOSE
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU.
MY NAME'S CAN REALLY WONG I
REPRESENTS ALSO THE SAME SCHOOL
CESSATION OF REALTORS AND I
OPPOSE FOURTEEN A TO HELLO
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ELAINE ONLY
BERMAN AND I AM A OF PUBLIC
SERVANT ACTUALLY FOR THE CITY OF
CONCORD ON THE RENT REVIEW PANEL.
AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL AND I'M
ASKING YOU FOR YOUR NO VOTE
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SO
MERE BEARD.
HI OPPOSE.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO MY LAYS DOWN
MEANWHILE I COME FROM ALAMEDA.
I'M A LITTLE AB -- FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO MY NAME IS DIANA
CLINE [inaudible]
FROM SACRAMENTO -- KNOLL ON
EIGHT ONE FOR A TOOL.
MY NAME IS THE SHEER LINE LONG I
COME FROM I TO THREE TOLL.
KNOLL AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO MY NAME ME
SIEU YOU IAN COLE.
I WANT TO SAY NO.
FOUR AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS THE TORTURE COOL I
COME FROM.
OUR STREET THOSE CITY.
HI A POLLS [inaudible]
A. B.. FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SUNNY
LIAM FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
AND A STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B..
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO MY NAME IS
JOANNE IRENE I'M FROM SAN
FRANCISCO AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS TONY LEE.
FROM SAN FRANCISCO AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO BOX ALBERT
TOTALLY SAN FRANCISCO STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO JUSTIN WITH
SAID SAM CISCO I STRONGLY OPPOSE.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO ACTUALLY
DHARTI SAN JOSE AND I STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO WILLIAM
SHARED AN INSTITUTE A REAL
ESTATE MANAGEMENT WE OPPOSE.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO MY NAME IS
DARREN KELLER WAS SAN FRANCISCO
I STRONGLY OPPOSE FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS JOHN DISORDER FROM
DANVILLE CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY.
OPPOSE -- A. B.. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO THANK.
SHANE CLARK SACRAMENTO STRONGLY
OPPOSE.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO FRIDA GORDON
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
INSTITUTE FOR REAL ESTATE
MANAGEMENT AND NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTY MANAGERS.
OPPOSE.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO PETER KAY
ZACH RENTAL OWNER IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY OPPOSE.
STEVE TALBERT OWNER OF THE
TOWNHOUSE APARTMENTS IN
FAIRFIELD CALIFORNIA CAME HERE
TO OPPOSE -- A. B. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS KIRK MACKENZIE I LIVE
IN SARATOGA AND I OWN A FEW
RENTAL UNITS IN THAT AREA AND
I'M ALSO HERE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION. TO ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU.
I AM SO THE I'M FROM OAKLAND
PLACES WITH RENT CONTROL TEND TO
HAVE THE WORST HOUSING CRISES.
THIS IS WHY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
NEIL CORKERY OAKLAND CALIFORNIA.
I OPPOSE AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO MY NAME IS
EBRAHIM BANGOR -- I'M
REPRESENTING THE LINES OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR COMMUTING
APARTMENT AND I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT OF FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
JIM ON ABOUT HOW TO THE WITH ACE
ALLIANCE OF CALIFORNIANS ARE
COMING EMPOWERMENT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. NINE SUPPORT OF
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO AND EIGHTY
THIRTY SIX AS WELL THANK YOU.
CITY WEBER FROM SACRAMENTO IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
ALSO I WANT TO LEAVE OFFER A
SUPPORT LETTER FROM PEACE
FREEDOM PARTY FOR MAYBE THIRTY
SIX SINCE IT'S BEEN PULLED.
MY NAME'S TIM KERN JUMP NO
CALIFORNIA OPPOSE.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANKS.
MY NAME IS PATRICIA MELODIC FROM
PAUL CALIFORNIA I OPPOSE
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KEVIN ON
BURKE I'M A RESIDENT LANDLORDS
HERE IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE BILL.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO WANT TO
THANK ALL OF YOU FOR COMING TO
PUBLIC COMMENT APPRECIATE YOUR
WAY IN IN -- ASK YOU TO EXCUSE
YOURSELVES AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE SO WE CAN.
ACCOMMODATE ANOTHER ROOM OF
PUBLIC COMMENTERS THANK YOU
.
I WANT TO WELCOME EVERYONE BACK
TO THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY OUT MEANT COMMITTEE
MEETING.
YOU ARE THE FOURTH ROOM A PUBLIC
COMMENTERS -- APPRECIATE
EVERYONE'S PATIENCE I WANT TO
JUST TAKE A MOMENT TO THANK THE
SERGEANTS FOR YOUR WORK IN
DEALING WITH THE LOGISTICS OF
TODAY.
LET ME JUST EXPLAIN TODAY'S
GROUND RULES BECAUSE WE WANT --
TO FOLKS AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
WERE ASKING EVERYONE. TO SAY
THIS THE FOLLOWING -- AND WE
NEED TO LIMIT IT TO THIS JUST SO
WE CAN CONTINUE TO MOVE
EXPEDITIOUSLY THROUGH TODAY --
IF YOU COULD STATE YOUR NAME ONE
AFFILIATION AND WHETHER YOU
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE THE ONE BILL
WE HAVE ON TODAY'S AGENDA -- AND
I WILL USE UP USE MYSELF AS AN
EXAMPLE MY NAME IS DAVID CHIU
I'M FROM SAN FRANCISCO AND I
SUPPORT THIS BILL -- I WILL
MENTION -- AB THIRTY SIX WAS
PULLED AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR LAST NIGHT UP BACK INTO
THE RULES COMMITTEE SO WE ONLY
HAVE AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO ON
THE DOCKET AND CONSIDERATION.
TODAY -- AND I ALSO ASK -- NO
SIGNS -- BECAUSE SIGNS IMPEDE
VIEWS -- THAT'S ONE OF THE RULES
IN OUR COMMITTEES AND OF COURSE
I ASK EVERYONE TO PLEASE BE
CIVIL AND COURTEOUS AND NOT
EXPRESS OPINIONS UNLESS YOU'RE
ON THE MIKE.
IF YOU HAVE TO EXPRESS AN
OPINION FEEL FREE TO USE JAZZ
HANDS.
WITH THAT.
IF WE COULD HEAR FROM OUR FIRST
PUBLIC COMMENTERS FOR THIS ROUTE.
HI MY NAME IS MARIA MOLINA
NATIVE A SAN FRANCISCO NOUN
CINEMA COUNTY I AM SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN TO EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU
THANK YOU PERFECT
.
HI AMBER NEED AMEND YOUR SON
FROM CINEMA COUNTY AND I SUPPORT
BILL FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK
YOU [inaudible]
I BEAR.
SUPPORT.
I PART [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS TO RESET -- FROM FROM
NORMAL COUNTY NOT VERY VERY
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU
.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS SYLVIA
SALINAS SEAN BEHALF OF CITY OF
LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE
AND I'D ALSO LIKE TO TESTIFY ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU HI SARAH SMITH WITH
TECH EQUITY COOPERATIVE I'M IN
SUPPORT OF THE SPELL.
HI MY NAME IS HERMAN CALDERON
WITH TECH EQUITY COLLABORATIVE
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
CALABRESE TECH EQUITY
COLLABORATIVE REPRESENTING
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA TECH
WORKERS WHO STRONGLY SUPPORT
BOTH BILLS.
MEGHAN ABLE TECH EQUITY
COOPERATIVE SUPPORT.
BACK A BLAZE ACT TECH EQUITY
COLLABORATIVE SUPPORT.
CHAU QUINCY JONES OF SACRAMENTO
AND SEIU LOCAL TWENTY FIFTEEN
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
JUDGE A BAND SACRAMENTO COUNTY --
SEIU LOCAL TWENTY ONE STRONG
SUPPORT BOTH BILLS FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO AND THIRTY SIX THANK
YOU.
I'M ANDREA NOVEL FROM SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA WITH LOCAL TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND RUN AND I SUPPORT AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THE I. GUIDE
US WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S STUDENTS
ASSOCIATION WE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
SAYS THE MAN AND AT LAKE HAS
PUBLIC AFFAIRS HERE ON BEHALF OF
TEAM G. PARTNERS -- IN SUPPORT
IF AMENDED TO ACCOUNT FOR
BANKING IN CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS
ALSO HERE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA EMB -- IN SUPPORT
ALIGNING THEIR COMMENTS WITH THE
TRADES AND LIKE TO EMPHASIZE
THAT THIS WILL NOT IMPACT
PRODUCTION THANK YOU.
HOLLY FIRMING OUTS WITH LIGHT
OUT PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF
THE ON NONPROFIT HOUSING
ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
EAST BAY SILICON VALLEY AND SB
AT HOME [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MASON AND THE AYE AYE ON BEHALF
OF WORKING PARTNERSHIPS AND
SILICON VALLEY RISING AND SO AND
SANTA CLARA COUNTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
ALEXANDER -- JUGA SEIU LOCAL
TWENTY FIFTEEN REPRESENTING LONG
TERM CARE GIVERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
CRYSTAL FROM SOME CISCO I
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
GOOD ON YOU WOULD YOU CHECK THE
CUPBOARD.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL BECAUSE I
MARCELLUS RECORDER I'M GOING TO
MONITOR WILL TEACH YOU DO GOT
WHAT.
WAS THE CONTENT.
OKAY MY NAME IS REGARDING --
COMING FROM SOME CISCO I HOPE
THAT'S GOVERNMENT WAS SUPPORT
THIS BILL FOR SIDE.
MY NAME IS SUNNY PENDERGRASS A
REPRESENT WOULD NOT REAL ESTATE
SERVICES AND I OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU A MELODY LARUE WOULD
NOT REAL ESTATE SERVICES AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
AND I THINK AND SALAS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN OPPOSITION.
ROGUE TOWN HALF OF HIM THE
ACTION A PRO HOUSING SUPPLY
ORGANIZATION THE BAY AREA WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
A ROBBER CULP SEC MY TENNIS YOU
STRONG SUPPORT.
CHRIS SERVICE FUNDS WHICH ARE
THE CALL THIS REMAIN IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS ORGANIZATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
YES ANY MENACE FROM LOS ANGELES
AND STRONG SUPPORT.
A BIGGER MESS ON BEHALF OF THE
LATINO COALITION FOR HOW THE
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
IN A SALOON ON BEHALF OF THE
LATINO COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS SELL CASTRO IN A I'M
FROM SAN JOSE A MEMBER OF PACKED
AND SAVE IT HARD.
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
HELLO DAVID CHIU MY NAME IS PAUL
SAID I'M CAN.
I'M A SECOND HEART CONTENT OF
DAY AND I SUPPORT FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU.
I'M RIDE -- SO WITH CIGARETTE
HEART HOUSING ACTION COMMITTEE
IN SAN JOSE AND WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
HI MY NAME IS ELIZABETH I RAN
SOUTH THEY ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
SICK OR HURT HOUSING ACTION
COMMITTEE -- AND IT -- WHICH IS
A PART OF THE P. P. CONE
CALIFORNIA NETWORK AND I STRONG
SUPPORT FOURTEEN EIGHTY FORTY ME
TO THINK IT.
HEY MY NAME IS SHAY I'M OUT HERE
TODAY IS A MEMBER OF ACE AND
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY SIX
AND FOURTEEN NINE EDT.
MY NAME IS JEFFERSON THE DM FROM
SACRAMENTO 'M WITH THE ALLIANCE
OF CALIFORNIANS FOR COMMUNITY
EMPOWERMENT.
I SUPPORT FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
AND A. B..
THIRTY SIX GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS TONY MAKE NEELAM WITH
FAITH IN THE VALLEY -- FIVE
COUNTIES THROUGHOUT THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND WE REPRESENT HUNDREDS
OF CONGREGATIONS AND WE STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF HIS.
HELLO EVERYONE I'M LATOYA AND I
SUPPORT -- FAITH IN THE VALLEY.
HELLO I'M JEFF RESULT FROM
SACRAMENTO I'M WITH WITH MY REAL
ESTATE SERVICES AND I OPPOSE.
MITCHELL PERCENT WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES WE ARE CO SPONSORS OF
THIS BILL AND STRONGLY SUPPORTED
THANK THE AUTHOR.
MY NAME IS SEVENTY AND I WAS MOM
FROM SAN FRANCISCO I'M FROM
FAITH IN ACTION BAY AREA AND
PICKLE CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE
HERE TO SUPPORT STRONGLY THE AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO THANK.
HI MY NAME IS REALLY THAT.
I CAN DO RAY WOULD TO CALIFORNIA
I HAVE I AM PAID INACTION
ORGANIZATION.
AND I SUPPORT BY ANYBODY IN THIS
THIS SITE -- AB THIRTY SIX
FOURTEEN NINETY TWO BECAUSE IT'S
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT FOR US.
I'M A STUFF AND I LIVE IN US
STANFORD AND I'M IN STRONG
STRONG SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS ADAM AND THURMOND A
GRAD STUDENT AT STANFORD AND A
RENTER -- AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
HI EVERYONE MY NAME IS CHRISTIAN
A LOT -- I'M ATTENDANT LIVING IN
SAN JOSE PART OF PACKED PEOPLE
ACTING COMMUNITY TOGETHER A PART
OF THE SILICON VALLEY VENTURE
TRIED COALITION PACKS ALSO PART
OF PEOPLE CALIFORNIA WHICH IS A
SPONSOR OF THESE BILLS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF BOTH AB THIRTY SIX IN
AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO HELLO I'M
VERNALIS AREN'T THEY AND I LIVE
IN SAN JOSE AND RENTER THEIR
IDEA.
M. WITH BACK.
AND THE PART OF BEAGLE I'M A
STRONG SUPPORTER OF AB. THIRTY
SIX AND FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO HI
MY NAME IS HER NAME WAY I'M WITH
HOUSING IS A HUMAN RIGHT THE
AIDS HEALTHCARE FOUNDATION
HOUSING ADVOCACY DIVISION.
WE SUPPORT THE CONCEPT BUT DON'T
BELIEVE AT THE CURRENT RATE
PROPOSED IS SUFFICIENT.
WITH YOUR MEMBERS RENT ONE OF
THE HAVE THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN A TWO AND CONCEPT BUT
OPPOSED TO THE CURRENT
PERCENTAGES IN THE BILL THANK
YOU.
SUSAN HUNTER LOS ANGELES TENANTS
UNION HOLLYWOOD LOCAL CASE
WORKER -- WOULD SPORTS --
PERSONALLYWOULD SUPPORT IF
AMENDED -- BUT OVERALL SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
TOM SCOTT WITH CAMBRIDGE
MANAGEMENT COMPANY IN SANTA
CLARA AYE OPPOSED THE BILL.
CAN REALLY ROSENBERG WITH US
YEAH YOU CALIFORNIA -- YOU
PERMITS EARLIER BELIEVERS IN
SUPPORT AND WE WANT TO DO
WHATEVER IT TAKES TO MOVE THIS
FORWARD THINKING.
MATT BROUGHT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
TEAMSTERS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ADEMAS FELT LIVE IN A SACRAMENTO
I OPPOSE THE BILL.
HELLO MY NAME IS JOSH FROM
ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
I AM GREG PLAYER FROM BACK OF
BILL AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
KERRY LIBERATE NATIVE
CALIFORNIAN I POSE.
NUMBER SEVEN MINORITY WILL MISS
BINGO HAVE GONE THOUGH SOME
MIGHT THEY'LL.
BETTER THAN THIS COP IN AXION
YEP FOR YOUR FOURTH AMENDMENT
LAPTOP WITHOUT.
I HAVE A I THINK THEY SAID HE'S
YEAH RICK THAT THERE'S A WHICH
IS THE DAY THOSE.
MY NAME IS SOMETHING TO BE EVERY
DAY LOVE MOST AND I'M I'M COMING
FROM SOME FRIENDSPHONE SOME NOT
THEY'LL COUNTY I AM A STRONG IN
SUPPORT OF THESE BILLS.
AB THIRTY SIX AND FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU SO MUCH
PROCESS.
MY NAME'S SALMON FOR MEDICAL --
I WILL KNOW ON THE P. THANK YOU.
TYRONE BUCKLEY ON BEHALF OF
HOUSING CALIFORNIA STRONG
SUPPORT AND ALSO SUPPORT OTHER
KEEP FAMILIES ON PACKAGE.
HI MY NAME IS IT'S EVEN MALL.
I COME FROM A SEVEN FOUR AS A
SICKLE.
I MADE MY CALL ME IS THE MY
FAMILY IS A SIX NUMBER -- SEE
NOW IS THE ONE FOUR AB ONE FOUR
EIGHTY TOOL.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS CATALOG THROW MORE
SAM BROWN ALL.
POSTED.
THE FORTY EIGHTY TOLL NO NO NO
SEC.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS GAVE
LEVY RV SANTA CLARA COUNTY
FIRMLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON PROCEEDS GO TO
WIN YES EIGHTH ARMED HOUSING
JUSTICE DIRECTOR AND WE THANK
THE CO AUTHORS AND ARE PROUD
SPONSORS OF BOTH A. B. THIRTY
SIX AND A. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO THANK YOU.
THIS IS BILL COHEN FROM SAM
CISCO I'M OPPOSED THIS BILL.
HI SENT THE ARRAY WITH THAT I
MANAGEMENT REPRESENTING
700-007-9000 APARTMENT UNITS IN
THE STATE I OPPOSE FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU.
CORNELIUS BURKE WITH THE BAY
AREA COUNCIL WE HAVE A SUPPORT
OF AMENDED POSITION.
MY NAME IS PROPERTY HEARING AND
I REPRESENT SEVEN THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED HOUSES PEOPLE IN SANTA
CLARA COUNTY.
ARE SO STRONGLY SUPPORT FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- FOR THIS BILL.
HELLO ERIC COST GARDEN FROM SAN
JOSE STRONGLY OPPOSED.
HI I AM BRIAN GEOGHEGAN
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT INDUSTRY AND I'M
OPPOSED.
TO FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO HELLO
THERE MCLAUGHLIN -- STRONGLY
OPPOSE FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU.
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR
COMING TO PROVIDE YOUR PUBLIC
COMMENT -- AT THIS TIME IF I
COULD ASK FOLKS IF YOU COULD
HOPEFULLY QUIETLY AND
EXPEDITIOUSLY -- STEP OUT SO
THAT WE CAN BRING IN ANOTHER
ROOM FULL OF PUBLIC COMMENTERS
THANK YOU FOR PARTICIPATING IN
TODAY'S HEARING
.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WANT TO
FIRST JUST THANK ALL OF YOU WHO
HAVE BEEN WAITING PATIENTLY TO
SPEAK IN PUBLIC COMMENT.
ARE WE HAVE JUST HAD FOUR ROOMS
WORTH A PUBLIC COMMENT. FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO STILL WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS YOUR PERSPECTIVE
I'M ASKING EVERYONE TO SAY THE
SAME THING SO THAT WE ALLOW
EVERYONE EQUAL TIME TO STATE
YOUR NAME. ONE AFFILIATION AND
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THE BIZ THIS BILL SO I'LL USE
THE EXAMPLE MY NAME IS DAVID
CHIU I'M FROM SAN FRANCISCO AND
I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
SO WITH THAT LET US GO TO OUR
NEXT PUBLIC COMMENTER.
DOZEN MEMBERS OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
HI JOHN SCOTT SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO HELLO AB FORTUNE EIGHT OLD
HUNTER PESAR LAUREL.
GOOD AFTERNOON BUT ONLY GETTING
BY WITH THE LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
FOR JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY
BASED ON THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
AND THE EASTERN COACHELLA VALLEY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND SO
IN SUPPORT OF THE ENTIRE KEEP.
FAMILY'S HOME PACKAGE.
MY NAME IS MICHAEL PIERCE FROM
FOSTER CITY CALIFORNIA I'M A
MARKET RATE AND LOW INCOME
HOUSING PROVIDER I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
BECAUSE DOESN'T PROVIDE MORE
HOUSING THANK YOU.
CHOI WAKES FROM PRESS THE
PROPERTY GROUP OUT OF SAN JOSE
AND AYE OPPOSED TO SPELL.
RAIN BEESON WITH THE NATIONAL
UNION OF HEALTH CARE WORKERS IN
SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS TO SEND THE TOWN I'M
FROM SAN FRANCISCO LOW ON AB.
EIGHTEEN FORTY TWO MULLIN
STEALING IT FROM SERVICES GO NO
A. B..
FORTY EIGHTY TWO MY KNEES HIS
OWN PHONE.
I AM FROM SALAS ICAL.
NO ON A. B. FOURTEEN IT IT'LL.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT OF
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO MY NAME IS A
REWARDING CAM FROM FREMONT.
OUR LOW ON A P. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TO N. A. B. THIRTY SIX PLEASE
HOLD LOW.
ON OUR A. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO
AND AB THIRTY SIX THANK YOU.
MY LAND SO HE SAYS POLAND'S
SOMEONE CISCO -- A. B. FORTY
EIGHT PEOPLE.
MY KNEES WAIT TIME.
I AM FROM SANTA SIX GO I
STRONGLY OPPOSE LISA BILL.
I'M POSI.
FULHAM SAN FRANCISCO TODAY I'M
HERE.
SAY NO FOR A. B..
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO NO MAN CAPS
LOWER INCOME TOTAL YOU MENTALLY
YOU WILL SEE RAIN COUNCILS LEVIN
SAYS.
SIX HEY I'M REYES FROM SAN
FRANCISCO I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO PLEASE WON'T
NO THANK YOU.
I'M JERRY TO FORM SAN FRANCISCO
REMOVAL.
A RENT A RENT CONTROL REPLACING
WITH THE TRAINING AND THE LAND
NO AGREEMENT -- CHANGE EACH.
SIXTEEN FORTY THOUSAND YOU'LL
REMEMBER TO FORTY THOUSAND OKAY
BYE THANK YOU WERE ASKING
EVERYONE JUST TO STATE YOUR NAME
AND AFFILIATION WHETHER OR NOT
YOU SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S FRANNIE
MOCK I REPRESENT THE ALA METER
PROPERTY OWNERS ASSOCIATION FROM
ALAMEDA CITY ALSO SMALLER
DEVELOPERS FROM SAN FRANCISCO
AND THE EAST BAY WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MATTHEW BAKER
PLANNING CONSERVATION THE
STRONGLY.
MY NAME IS ON YOUR WITH A STRONG
SUPPORT FOR A BI THIRTY SIX AND
AB.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO MY NAME IS
NICOLE DEAN OUR ORGANIZE WITH
EIGHTY SOME FROM OAKLAND AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT ALL THE BILLS
IN THE KEEP CALIFORNIA FAMILIES
HOME PACKAGE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
CAROL.
FIVE OAKLAND AND A SAN FRANCISCO
STRONG SUPPORT AB THIRTY SIX A.
B..
FOURTEEN EIGHTY TWO GOOD MORNING
MY NAME SHE NEEDS LEGAL I'M HERE
REPRESENTING POLICY LINK IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THE SPELL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC THEY WISH TO SPEAK IN
PUBLIC COMMENT EITHER IN SUPPORT.
OF THE BILL OR OPPOSED TO THE
BILL.
THE SERGEANTS BRINGING OTHERS IN.
WELL DONE OKAY.
AGAIN IF THERE ANY OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC THE WISH TO SPEAK
IN PUBLIC COMMENT EITHER IN
SUPPORT OR IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SEEING NONE PUBLIC COMMENT AT
THIS TIME IS CLOSE.
THIS ITEM IS BACK IN THE HANDS
OF THE COMMITTEE -- OUR VICE
CHAIR AND IT WAS MAKING HIS WAY
BACK BUT IN THE MEANTIME I'M
GONNA HAND THE GAVEL OVER TO MS
QUIRK SILVA -- AND I WILL GO
BACK TO THE DíAS.
THERE YOU GO.
OKAY -- NOW WE HAVE DISPENSED
WITH PUBLIC COMMENTS I WILL --
BRING THE ISSUE BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
[inaudible]
MR GLORIA.
THE FAMOUS BYE SHARE -- AND I'LL
TAKE THE AUTHOR CHAIRMAN OF FOR
THIS BUILDING -- MY NAME IS TODD
GLORIA TENET FROM SAN DIEGO I'M
SUPPORTING THE BILL -- SORRY
DEPUTATION YOU HERE IS SO OFTEN --
I APPRECIATE THE WORK THIS PUT
ON THIS MISTER MISTER WOULD YOU
CHARACTERIZE THIS BILL AS A WORK
IN PROGRESS.
ABSOLUTELY WHAT.
CAN YOU TALK ABOUT MAYBE SOME
AREAS WHERE YOU THINK THAT THERE
MAY BE SOME INFLUENCE OVER SOME
ADDITIONAL CONVERSATION A
CONSIDERATION MAYBE BUT BASS IN
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY.
OR THROUGH THE CONVERSATIONS YOU
IN YOUR OFFICES HAD.
SO.
I TOOK A COUPLE OF NOTES --
DURING THE OPPOSITION TESTIMONY
AND ONE OF THE THINGS ALL SAY IS --
THIS WAS THE FIRST TIME I THINK
THAT SOME OF THE OPPOSITION HAS
PUBLICLY STATED SOME OF THE
POTENTIAL PLACES THEY THE MAN
THAT THEY MIGHT GO.
SO I HEARD FROM CA -- THE
POSSIBILITY OF THINKING ABOUT
CPI PLUS SEVEN THE OREGON MODEL --
THINKING ABOUT ASKING FOR A
SITUATION -- OR ADDRESSING THE
ISSUE OF OF NEW CONSTRUCTION I
HEARD FROM THE CHAMBER THE
POSSIBILITY THAT IF FOR
FOLLOWING THE CASA MATA WHICH
WAS CPI PLUS.
FIVE SOME DESIRE THINK ABOUT TEN
IMPROVEMENTS IN PASS THROUGHS OR
SUNSETS HERE'S WHAT I WOULD SAY
ABOUT ALL OF THAT I'M NOT
PREPARED TO COMMIT TO ANY OF
THESE ISSUES TODAY BUT BUT
CERTAINLY.
HEARING THEM PUT ON THE TABLE --
I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT AND
AND I THINK WE WILL CERTAINLY BE
HAVING DISCUSSIONS -- IN THE
COMING DAYS AND WEEKS -- AS WE
AS WE HOPE TO MOVE THIS.
FOR I THINK JUST EXPLAINING THAT
PARTICULARLY NOTING THIS THE
FIRST COMMITTEE -- HEARING FOR
THIS BILL -- IS IMPORTANT IS
SORT OF INDICATE WE AWARE ARE
AREAS OF GIVE IN I WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE -- CERTAINLY FOLKS
FROM -- THE BUILDING OWNERS ARE
PROPERTY MANAGERS FOR BEING AT
THE TABLE AND INDICATING THE
LEVEL OF OPENNESS THAT FRANKLY
IS NEW -- AND THAT SHOULD BE
APPRECIATED A KNOWLEDGE -- AND
AND THIS MY GRATITUDE FOR THAT I
RECOGNIZE THAT OF A SHIFT IN
PERHAPS PREVIOUS -- EFFORTS --
INDEED YEAH I THINK EVERY
MEMBERS COMMITTEE -- WOULD
PROBABLY BE GRATEFUL FOR THE
WILL IS TO BE AT THE TABLE TO
HAVE THE CONVERSATIONS IDENTIFY
THINGS THAT NEED WORK AS OPPOSED
REFLECTS OF NO.
I THINK IT SIGNALS THAT WE ALL
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S A CRISIS
IN THE STATE THE RENT IS TOO
HIGH AND WE SHOULD DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT.
AND WHEN BOTH SIDES OF THIS
ISSUE -- ARE SAYING THAT THAT
GIVES ME A SENSE AS A DECISION
MAKER THAT THERE'S SOMETHING
THAT CAN BE DONE HERE -- SO I
WOULD BE INTERESTED IN A
CONTINUE TALK ABOUT YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY PERCENTAGES I THINK A
REALLY IMPORTANT -- I THINK AN
UNDERSTANDING THAT WHAT THE THIS
SHOULD NEVER BE ABOUT --
STIFLING PRODUCTION -- WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS IS REALLY AN
ISSUE ABOUT A SUPPLY -- THAT WE
HAVE NOT BUILT ENOUGH HOMES IN
THE STATE FOR DECADES AND
DECADES -- AND THAT WE THAT IS
THE TRUE SOLUTION IN THE LONG
TERM BUT THEY ARE SHORT TERM
PAIN THAT SO MANY OF US FEEL --
THAT THIS LEGISLATURE NEEDS TAKE
ACTION UPON AND I NOTE THE
COMMENTS OF THE BUILDING TRADES
SO I THINK THAT WAS EXACTLY WHAT
AWAY THEY'RE TALKING.
I THINK AS WORKING MIDDLE CLASS
PEOPLE OF WILL BUILD A LOT OF
STUFF I KNOW THIS PROBABLY FEW
FOLKS BETTER SUITED TO EXPLAIN --
WHY WE NEED PROBABLY A NOT AN
EITHER OR BUT A A BOTH A AND
APPROACH -- ON I ASSEMBLY SO I
PREACH THE THE OF THIS OR NOT
STIFLING DEVELOPMENT I THINK THE
BILL CURRENTLY IS SILENT.
ON HOW THIS MIGHT APPLY TO NEW
CONSTRUCTION IS THAT RIGHT IT IS.
AND SO THAT I THINK IS NECESSARY
I WOULD POINT OUT THAT FROM MY
EXPERIENCES AS A HOUSING
COMMISSIONER THE PHARMACY
COUNCILMEMBER FORMER MAYOR OF
SAN DIEGO I GET.
THAT -- I UNDERSTAND IT LANDED
ON THE TO EXTEND THE PROGRAM
THAT AROUND -- I THINK THE THE
PERFORMERS THAT ARE NECESSARY TO
FINANCE NEW CONSTRUCTION -- DO
NOT RELY UPON RENTAL EIGHT YOU
OF YOUR ANNUAL RENT INCREASES OF
AT THE ARE UNDER THIS BILL YOU
CAN BE A MAXIMUM ABOUT 8% MORE
OR LESS.
I DON'T THINK ANYONE REALLY
NEEDS THAT TO GET FINANCING AND
SO I THINK THAT YOUR CURRENT
POSITION IS WORTHY OF SUPPORT
TODAY.
IF WE CAN SEE DATA THAT
SUGGESTED DIFFERENT APPROACH --
THAT'S CERTAINLY SOMETHING THIS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD BE
INTERESTED IN -- IN TERMS OF THE
REST OF THE BILL -- I CAN CHECK
MY SURE MY COLLEAGUES WILL WILL --
WILL UPON FURTHER.
HI I WOULD JUST I GUESS I'D WRAP
UP BY SAYING SO RECOGNIZE TIME
IS OF THE ESSENCE.
IS THAT I WOULD WANT TO
APPRECIATE AND THANK THE TURNER
CENTER FOR I THINK REALLY
HELPING.
TO START THIS CONVERSATION -- IN
THE AFTERMATH OF LAST YEAR'S
PROPOSITION -- TEN THAT COULD
NOT BE THE END OF THE
CONVERSATION AND REALLY
PROVIDING -- I THINK A A VERY
REASONABLE APPROACH -- THERE WAS
A NEW STORY -- IN MY IN SAN
DIEGO -- THIS PAST WEEK OF A
PROPERTY OWNER.
IN I BELIEVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GONZALEZ IS DISTRICT -- WITH --
75% RENT INCREASE.
I DON'T BELIEVE THAT THERE'S
ANYONE ON EITHER SIDE OF THE
ISSUE TODAY THEY COULD STAND UP
OR DEFEND THAT KIND OF INCREASE.
AND WHAT I LIKE ABOUT THIS BILL
IS THAT WE KIND INCREASE WOULD
BE ILLEGAL -- IF IT WERE TO BE
LAW -- THAT KIND OF GOUGING HAS
NO PLACE -- IN CALIFORNIA -- AND
WE SHOULD DO SOMETHING TO STOP
THAT -- I THINK THE INDUSTRY
DOES A FINE JOB OF OF OF TRYING
TO GET AMONG SOME SORT OF
RECOGNIZES OUR OUT LIARS -- BUT
NO ONE SHOULD HAVE TO BUDGET FOR
THAT AND I THINK ONE OF THE
WITNESSES SPOKE VERY ELOQUENTLY --
TO THAT -- IS SO -- I THINK THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF GOOD TO SAID
SUPPORT HERE I GO I THINK THE I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT ABOUT THIS
LEGISLATION.
IS A STATE WIDE NATURE OF IT --
I RECOGNIZE THAT NOT EVEN IF
COSTA HAWKINS WERE REFORM TO
REPEALED NOT EVERY COMMUNITY
WOULD ADOPT IT -- INTO THAT
WOULD LEAVE US MAYBE PROBABLY A
GOOD NUMBER CITIES I REPRESENT --
UNPROTECTED FOR THEIR TENANTS --
THIS BILL TAKES A DIFFERENT MORE
UNIVERSAL APPROACH -- THAT I
THINK IS -- BENEFICIAL WHEN WE
KNOWLEDGE IS A STATE WIDE CRISIS
AND SO THAT'S AN INHERENT VALUE
IN THIS BILL -- SO THERE'S A LOT
TO SUPPORT HERE TODAY MISTER
CHAIRMAN I'M HAPPY TO MAKE A
MOTION -- TO ADVANCE THIS BILL
WITH YOUR ASSURANCES THAT THIS
IS VERY MUCH A WORK IN PROGRESS --
AND THAT STAKEHOLDERS ON BOTH
SIDES ARE WILLING TO KEEP THIS
CONVERSATION GOING -- AS A
TENANT I UNDERSTAND THIS -- BUT
I'M A TENANT WHO HAS A PRETTY
DECENT SALARY -- AND SO I
RECOGNIZE THAT I EVEN IF I MAY
NOT BE A PROPERTY AND I STILL
SIT HERE TO PRIVILEGED POSITION --
BUT I DO WANT TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO EVERY
TIME THEY GO TO THE DOOR THEIR
APARTMENT AND THEY SEE A NOTICE
FROM THEIR PROPERTY.
MANAGER ON THE DOOR -- THEIR
HEART SINKS A LITTLE BIT -- THEY
GET VERY VERY NERVOUS IN IF
YOU'RE LIKE ME MOST THE TIME
IT'S ABOUT MAINTENANCE IN THE
BUILDING.
BUT A GOOD CHUNK OF TIME IT'S
ABOUT A RENT INCREASE AND YOU
JUST HOPE IT'S SOMETHING THAT
YOU CAN AFFORD AGAIN I'M BLESSED
AND FORTUNATE TO BE IN A
POSITION THAT GENERALLY I CAN --
BUT I KNOW THAT'S NOT THE CASE
FOR MANY MANY CALIFORNIANS I
KNOW THAT YOU KNOW MISTER
CHAIRMAN THAT'S NOT THE CASE FOR
MANY CALIFORNIANS THIS BILL IS A
RESPONSE TO THAT.
AND I THINK IT'S A GREAT DEAL
PROMISE HERE THAT IS WORTHY OF
CONTINUE DIALOGUE I HOPE MY
COLLEAGUES WILL JOIN ME STAND
SUPPORTING THIS LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU WAS A GLORIA ANY OTHER
COMMENTS FROM -- MIST -- QUIRK
SILVA.
AGAIN THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD -- THIS
WEEK IN THE BUILDING AS WE SAY
THE CAPITAL THERE IS BEEN MANY --
VITAL DISCUSSIONS UNDER MANY
ISSUES WHETHER IT'S HOUSING
WHETHER IT'S VACCINATIONS.
MANY ISSUES THAT WE BRING --
THIS HOUSE -- O INVITE PEOPLE
TO SAY WE WANT TO HEAR FROM YOU
AND THOSE ISSUES ARE.
HOTLY DISCUSSED.
OR EVEN MORE THAN THAT CONTESTED
AND I THINK THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION IS THE SAME IN THE
SENSE THAT WE COULD CLEARLY SEE
BY THOSE WHO WHO CAME TO THE
CAPITOL.
WE HAVE MANY THAT OPPOSE AND
MANY THAT SUPPORT.
AND AS SOMEBODY WHO REPRESENTS
NORTH ORANGE COUNTY.
HI TO SEE THE NEED.
FOR LOOKING AT RENTS ACROSS THE
STATE AND LOOKING TEN ADDRESS AN
ISSUE AND NO MATTER WHERE WE END
UP WITH THIS BILL WE'RE
CERTAINLY GOING TO HAVE A A
SPLIT.
OF OPINION ABOUT DID WE DO THE
RIGHT THING BUT THIS BILL AGAIN
LIKE MY COLLEAGUE SAID ATTEMPTS
TO MAKE A STEP INTO THIS
DISCUSSION IT'D TEMPS.
TO LOOK AT DATA AS YOU BROUGHT
FORWARD TO SAY.
CAN THERE BE COMMON GROUND AND I
TO DO SUPPORT THIS BILL -- BUT
WOULD SERIOUSLY.
AND HAVE SERIOUSLY MADE SPECIFIC
RECOMMENDATIONS -- FOR AS THE
THE BILL MOVES FORWARD TO THE
FLOOR THAT.
WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
SPECIFY THOSE WHICH IS CONTINUE
TO WORK ON STABILITY AND MAKING
SURE THAT.
IF THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD THAT
WEREN'T GOING TO HAVE SOME KIND
OF STABILITY NOT ONLY FOR OUR
THE RENTERS BUT FOR THE ROAD THE
OWNER SAID THAT THIS CANNOT BE
CHANGED EVERY.
YEAR TWO YEARS SECOND ONLY
ADDRESSING THE NEW CONSTRUCTION
AS YOU.
NOTED WE NO WE HAVE A HOUSING
CRISIS AND BUILDING UNITS AND
BUILDING HOMES AS PART OF THE
REASON SO MAKING SURE WE ADDRESS
THAT.
AND PERHAPS REALLY LOOKING AT
LOOKING AT THE BALLOT GOING
TOWARDS A POINT WHERE WE KNOW WE
JUST LEFT THE BALLOT ON A AND
E'S MY DISTRICT IT WAS A VERY
SPLIT -- OPINION -- ACTUALLY
MORE OPPOSED TO ON RENT CONTROL
THEN -- SUPPORTING IT -- BUT
JUST THIS WEEK THINGS CHANGE
CONSTANTLY -- WE HAD AND MY OWN --
DISTRICT FULLER TEN AND ANAHEIM --
MOBILE HOME PARK OWNER KNEW WHO
CAME IN AND DID ALMOST A 3100%
NOW THIS WAS OF COURSE CONTESTED
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL THROUGH THE
CITY COUNCIL'S FULLER CAN ADD
ANAHEIM.
AND I KNOW THAT THIS OPERATOR IS
NOT ONE OF THE OPERATORS -- THAT
MANY OF THE PEOPLE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA HAVE HE IS AND IN
ESSENCE MOVING TOWARDS THE
GALGIANI PART THAT -- BRINGS
THIS BILL FORWARD.
BUT WE CAN'T CONTROL ALL OF
THOSE SO WITH THIS BILL MY HOPE
IS THAT THERE CAN BE SOME KIND
OF ASSURANCE.
THAT AS IT MOVES FORWARD AGAIN.
WE ARE MOVING TOWARDS THE CENTER
AND WE MOVE TOWARDS THE CENTER
WE OFTEN SEE.
NEED EITHER SIDE ARE NOT
COMPLETELY HAPPY BUT SOMETIMES
THAT'S WHERE WE'RE GONNA END UP
HAVING TAKEN STEPS TOWARDS THE
MIDDLE SO WITH THAT I WOULD TO
SECOND THE MOTION -- AND AGAIN
MAKING SURE THAT.
IF THE BILL COMES TO THE FLOOR
WITH OUT ADDITIONAL -- TYPES OF
ASSURANCES THAT I WOULD RESERVE
MY VOTE AS A NO VOTE IF THERE'S
NOT ANY CHANGE ON THE FLOOR BUT
TODAY I WILL MOVE IT FORWARD.
THANK YOU MISS -- QUIRK SILVA
ANNEX I HAVE I COULD ACTUALLY
RESPOND TO IF A FEW THESE POINTS
SO FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- FOR FOR YOUR COMMENTS
AND AND FOR YOUR ENGAGEMENT ON
THIS AND I I WANT TO THANK EACH
AND EVERYONE OF YOU -- I KNOW.
ALL OF YOU'VE SPENT QUITE A BIT
OF TIME THINKING ABOUT THIS
DISCUSSING THIS AND AND I'M VERY
GRATEFUL THAT YOU HAVE DONE THAT --
WITH REGARD TO THE TOPIC OF
STABILITY I DON'T THINK ANY OF
US WANT TO BE BACK HERE NEXT
YEAR OR TWO YEARS FROM NOW OUR
FIERCER NOW I CAN TELL YOU.
IF WE ARE ABLE TO GET THIS TO
THE FINISH LINE I WILL NOT WANT.
TO REVISIT THIS CONVERSATION
ANYTIME IN THE NEAR FUTURE SO --
I'M COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
YOU AND OTHERS TO THINK THROUGH
HOW WE CAN ACHIEVE SOME LEVEL OF
STABILITY BOTH SAID THAT WERE
NOT.
IN THIS LEGISLATIVE PROCESS YEAR
AFTER YEAR BUT ALSO TO PROVIDE
THE MARKETS WITH SOME CERTAINTY
OF OF OF EXPECTATIONS -- ON
ISSUES OF NEW CONSTRUCTION AND
OTHERS -- AS I'VE SID I'M OPEN
TO THE CONVERSATION WHAT I WOULD
LIKE TO ASK AND I WILL PUBLICLY
**** AGAIN.
I IS FOR MORE DATA. TO INFORM
THE DISCUSSION -- I PUT TO BOTH
SIDES REQUEST FOR DATA I HAVE
CIRCULATED TO THE PUBLIC A
SEVENTEEN PAGE DOCUMENT THAT
LAYS OUT.
THE JUSTIFICATION FOR CPI PLUS
5% AND AS I SAID IN MY OPENING
COMMENTS.
STE THE DATA FROM THE BUREAU OF
LABOR STATISTICS SHOWS THAT CPI
PLUS 5% IS A 100% HIGHER.
THAN THE ACTUAL MEDIAN ANNUAL
RENT INCREASE IN EACH OF THE
STATE'S LARGEST REGION'S CPI
PLUS FIVE OVER THE PAST TEN
YEARS WOULD HAVE ALLOWED RENT
INCREASES FOUR TIMES FASTER.
THAN SIMILAR RENT INCREASES IN
OUR STATE SO.
WE HAVE DATA THAT SHOWS THAT BUT
IF THERE IS DATA THAT SHOWS A
JUSTIFICATION FOR A HIGHER
NUMBER OR FOR NEW CONSTRUCTION I
WOULD LIKE TO UNDERSTAND THAT.
WITH THE COPY OUT THAT IN THE IN
A MAJOR SHIFT IN A LITTLE BIT
BUT USING THE EXAMPLE.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE WHEN
COSTA HAWKINS WAS DEBATED THE
IDEA WAS TO EXEMPT OUT NEW
CONSTRUCTION.
AND WHAT THAT STORY IN IN IN THE
pTHEY DID IN MOST RENT CONTROL
CITIES LIKE SAN FRANCISCO.
IS IT FROZE THE APPLICATION OF
RENT CONTROL -- TOO BUILDINGS
THAT WERE BUILT BEFORE A CERTAIN
DATE AND MIGHT CITIES EXAMPLE.
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE THAT IS
HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY NEGATIVE
IMPACTS AND I'M NOT SAYING THIS
IS NOT RENT CONTROL THIS IS A
DIFFERENT CONTEXT.
BUT WE JUST HAVE TO BE CAREFUL
IN HOW WE GO ABOUT IT BUT ALL
THAT BEING SAID IF THEY'RE FACTS
AND DATA THAT UNDERPIN THIS.
WE VERY MUCH WANT TO GO TO
RECEIVE THAT I'VE I'VE ASKED
INDUSTRY FOR THAT INFORMATION
AND AND HOPE THAT THAT WILL
INFORM THE DISCUSSION THAT'S
WHAT I WANT. TO TO DRIVE THIS
BECAUSE I THINK IT'S EASY TO
ALLOW.
IDEOLOGICAL PERSPECTIVES OR
WHERE WE WANT TO SIDE ONE WITH
THE OTHER TO DRIVE IT BUT WE ARE
JOB AS DELIBERATE OF
POLICYMAKERS IS TO USE FACTS AND
DATA. TO GET TO THE RIGHT ANSWER
TO ENSURE THAT OUR STATE
PROTECTS OUR RESIDENTS BUT ALSO
PROTECTS.
THE ABILITY OF OF THE HOUSING
MARKET TO TO FUNCTION WELL.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
MISTER MISTER MENTORING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN --
IN THANK YOU -- MISSED YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS ISSUE TODAY AND
FOR YOUR WORK -- YOU KNOW YOU'RE
VERY HARD WORK ON THIS ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE -- I KNOW IT'S
IT'S BEEN A LONG HEARING IT'S
LATE IT'S THURSDAY EVERYBODY
WANTS TO GET BACK HOME AND TO
THEIR DISTRICTS -- SO I WILL BE
BRIEF IN MY COMMENTS AND I WOULD
ALIGN MYSELF A VERY CLOSELY WITH
THE COMMENTS OF MY FRIEND AND
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO WHO.
I THOUGHT WAS SPOT ON A HIT IT
OUT OF THE PARK ABOUT YOUR
COMMENTS WERE GREAT AND AND I
WOULD BASICALLY SAY DITTO TO
EVERYTHING THAT -- MY COLLEAGUE
SAID -- BUT I I WANT -- TO MAKE
SOME SLIGHT ADDITIONS AND JUST
SAY I TO SUPPORT THIS NOTION OF
STABILITY I THINK IT'S
SIGNIFICANT.
AND I THINK FOR A LOT OF REASONS
ONE IS OP FOR OBVIOUS REASONS
JUST AS A LEGISLATIVE BODY ON A
REAP REVISITING THIS EVERY
SINGLE YEAR -- BUT CERTAINLY I
THINK PEOPLE ON ON ON EITHER
SIDE OF THIS ISSUE ARE ALL SIDES
OF THIS ISSUE DON'T WANT SOME
PING PONG UNITS BACK IN OUR UP
DOWN UP DOWN.
YEAR IN YEAR OUT THERE'S A LACK
OF CERTAINTY AND THAT I THINK
THAT LACK OF CERTAINTY HURTS
EVERYBODY -- I'M GLAD TO HEAR
YOU SAY YOU KNOW YOU YOU AND YOU
YOU HAVE SUFFERED YOU SAY IT A
NUMBER OF TIMES -- THAT YOU WANT
THIS TO BE DATA DRIVEN YOU WANT
PEOPLE TO BRING IT OUT I THINK
IT'S ALWAYS BETTER TO HAVE IT BE.
HAVE SOMETHING LEGISLATION BE
DONE BY FAX -- I THINK IS IS --
IMPORT I'M GLAD TO HEAR YOU --
SAY THAT THIS IS A VERY REAL
ISSUE FOR A WHOLE LOT OF PEOPLE
AND PEOPLE ARE NERVOUS.
THERE OFTENTIMES ONLY A PAYCHECK
AWAY OR A NOTICE LITTLE BACK YOU
KNOW PIECE OF PAPER ON THEIR
DOOR AWAY FROM FROM LOSING THEIR
RENTAL PROPERTY FROM LOSING
THEIR ABILITY TO HOUSE
THEMSELVES.
AND THEIR FAMILY AND I THINK TO
YOU KNOW TAKE A IT'S SORT OF
BEEN BEATING LIKE A DRUM.
BUT IT DOES BEAR REPEATING THAT
THAT THERE'S A LACK OF SUPPLY
ISSUE BUT ALSO TO BE ADDED TO
THAT TOO IS THERE'S A LACK OF
INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUE BECAUSE
WHAT GOES WITH SUPPLY OF HOUSING.
IS THERE HAS TO BE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE TO
SUPPORT THAT HOUSING THERE HAS
TO BE ROSE RECIPE WATER THERE
HAS TO BE.
A QUALITY OF LIFE IF YOU'RE EVEN
IF WE WERE TO BUILD ALL THESE
UNITS WITHOUT THE FOR EXAMPLE
THE ROADS TO SUPPORT THOSE UNITS
FOR THE TRANSPORTATION. TO
SUPPORT THOSE UNITS THIRTY
SECOND TRAFFIC THE QUALITY OF
LIFE SO I THINK IT.
IT'S MORE WHEN WE NEED TO BE
SICK TALKING ABOUT MORE THAN
JUST SUPPLY IT'S CLEARLY A
SUPPLY -- BUT WITHOUT SUPPLY
COMES.
A WHOLE LOT OF OTHER THINGS THAT
THE STATE -- IN THE STATE NEEDS
TO BE PREPARED INVEST IN OR
YOU'RE JUST GONNA HAVE PEOPLE
THAT MAYBE HAVE A HOUSING UNIT
BUT THEY CAN'T GET ANYWHERE.
IS A CAN'T THE THE THEY'RE NOT
NEAR MASS TRANSIT THEY DON'T
HAVE MASS TRANSIT OPTIONS.
THEY'RE TRAPPED THERE ROADS ARE
STUCK IN GRIDLOCK.
WATER IS ALWAYS GOING TO BE AN
ISSUE HERE IN CALIFORNIA SO I
THINK TO WE NEED TO COLLECTIVELY
AS A BODY BE THINKING OF THAT AS
WELL SO.
I I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE
MEASURE AT TODAY LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS AS IT.
HEADS TO THE FOUR THINGS AMONG.
THANK YOU.
I THINK THERE'S BEEN A VERY
HEFTY CONVERSATION -- AROUND
HOUSING ISSUES NOT JUST THIS
WEEK BUT I MEAN OVER THE YEARS --
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN WHEN I GOT
ELECTED I ASKED AND REQUESTED TO
BE ON THE HOUSING COMMITTEE AND
BECAUSE IT'S AN ISSUE THAT'S
IMPORTANT NOT JUST TO MY
DISTRICT BUT TO THE ENTIRE STATE.
AND OVER THE LAST THREE YEARS WE
HAVE ENGAGED IN A CONVERSATION
ABOUT HUNDREDS OF BILLS RELATED
TO HOUSING.
AND APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
FORTY SEVEN OF THOSE PASSED OUT
OF THIS HOUSE AT AT THE STATE
ASSEMBLY.
WE MOVED THEM FORWARD SO.
WHAT WE TAKE FROM THAT IS THAT
THERE IS NOT ONE SOLUTION TO
SOLUTIONS OR THREE SOLUTIONS IT
TAKES YEARS OF DISCUSSION TO
ADDRESS THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY?
AND FIFTY EIGHT STATES AND FORTY
MILLION PEOPLE -- FIFTY SIX
COUNTIES AND FORTY MILLION
PEOPLE LIVING IN THE STATE THE
HOUSING CONVERSATION IS MUCH
MORE COMPLICATED THAN ONE SINGLE
BILL.
I APPRECIATE EVERY SINGLE PERSON
WHO HAS REACHED OUT TO OUR
OFFICES.
WHO HAS TAKEN THE TIME? TO
EXPRESS THEIR CONCERN OVER
AFFORDABILITY -- OVER.
AT HOUSING OVERALL IN THE STATE.
IT IS ALSO CLEAR TO ME THAT AT
EVERY COUNTY LOOKS AND ADDRESSES
THIS IN SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT WAY
BECAUSE OUR NEEDS ARE DIFFERENT --
EIGHTY IN THE COUNTIES THAT I
REPRESENT I THINK A LOT ABOUT
WHAT WE EXPERIENCED IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND WHAT RANK DOUCHING
MEANT. TO FIRE STRICKEN AND
DEBRIS FLOWS STRICKEN
COMMUNITIES WHERE WE LOST. TOO
MANY HUMAN LIVES.
ARE IN I KNOW THAT WHEN WE
IMPLEMENTED THE LAW THAT WAS IN
PLACE AROUND EMERGENCY -- RANK
COUCHING IT HELPED KEEP PEOPLE --
IN THEIR HOMES BECAUSE WE HAD
LOST SO MANY HOMES AND IT ALSO
GAVE THOSE THAT HAD LOST HOMES
THE OPPORTUNITY TO FIND
SOMETHING -- THAT.
WAS GOING TO HELP THEM NOT JUST
IN THE NEAR FUTURE BUT A IN THE
FAR FUTURE AS WELL.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE -- THAT OUR WORK IS
NOT DONE WITH THIS BILL I
APPRECIATE THAT THEIR HAT WHAT
I'VE HEARD AND TAKEN AWAY FROM
THE CONVERSATIONS THE AUTHOR --
IS THAT THIS IS A WORK IN
PROGRESS AT THE CONVERSATION
CONTINUES THAT THERE IS AN
UNDERSTANDING AND AWARENESS THAT
ARE COUNTIES ARE DIFFERENT --
AND WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS THIS IN MANY DIFFERENT
FORMS AND BILLS -- BUT ALSO THAT
WE HAVE AN INTEREST IN NOT
BRINGING.
THIS PARTICULAR -- PERCENTAGE
CONVERSATION BACK ON A REGULAR
BASIS THAT WE COULD.
PERHAPS FIND A WAY TO COMMIT --
TO NOT REVISITING THIS ON A
REGULAR BASIS I WANT THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA TO KNOW THAT THE
CASE THAT.
THE STATE LEGISLATURE CARES AND
WE WOULDN'T CARE IF WE WEREN'T
REALLY.
LOOKING AT THE THE NUMBER OF
BILLS THAT WE HAVE AND IF WE
WOULDN'T HAVE PUT ANY THOUGHT
INTO IT -- I KNOW THAT I HAVE
SPOKEN TO A NUMBER OF MY
COLLEAGUES ON THIS DíAS. TO
EXTENSIVE LINKS UP ABOUT WHAT
CALIFORNIA CAN DO -- NOT JUST
THIS WEEK BUT IN IN THE WEEKS
COMING AND WE DON'T WHETHER
WE'RE ON THE SAME SIDE OF THE
AISLE ARE NOT WE DON'T ALWAYS
AGREE AND SOMETIMES WE AGREE.
BECAUSE A LOT OF OUR EXPERIENCE --
AND THE VOICES OF OUR DISTRICT
SHAPE HOW WE THINK ABOUT THE
ISSUES -- SO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY I
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA KNOW THAT
WE CARE THAT WE'RE TAKING THIS
SERIOUSLY THAT THESE ARE HARD
CONVERSATIONS AND THAT OUR STATE.
IS SUCH A BIG STATE AND
COMPLICATED IN SO MANY WAYS --
BUT THAT WE'VE MADE A COMMITMENT
TO LOOK AT THIS AND I THINK
THAT'S EVIDENCED BY THE NUMBER
OF BILLS THAT HAVE BEEN HEARD
AND THE NUMBER OF BILLS THAT
THIS HOUSE HAS MOVED FORWARD.
IF I COULD JUST MAKE A COUPLE OF
COMMENTS -- RELATED TO THAT SO --
YOU REFERENCED YEAR ON DISTRICTS
AND THE CHALLENGES YOU'VE HAD
WITH WILD FIRES AND MUD SLIDES
AND IN -- TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN I
MOVE FOR THE BILL THAT WAS
SIGNED INTO LAW -- TO I WOULD
DESCRIBE STRICTLY SLIGHTLY
STRENGTHENED THE PRICE GOUGING
STATUTE THAT I REFERENCE THAT
CAN ONLY BE INVOKED IN THE EVENT
OF A NATURAL DISASTER OR SOME
SORT OF DECLARED EMERGENCY AND
AND THAT WAS.
WHEN I STARTED THINKING ABOUT A
MODEL LIKE THIS OF OF OF SOME
SORT OF ANTI?
GOUGING STATUTE -- MR GLORIA
REFERENCE THE FACT THAT IT'S
GOOD TO HAVE A STATEWIDE
STANDARD ONE THING I WANT JUST
POINT OUT ABOUT THIS BILL IS WE
AMENDED THE BILL WITH THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS TO INCORPORATE THE
CONCEPT OF A REGIONAL CPI WHICH
ARE NUMBERS THAT EXIST.
BUT TO ALLOW FOR THE FLEXIBILITY
OF HOW.
UP MORE REGIONAL ECONOMIES
AROUND THE STATE ARE ARE DOING --
TO RELATE TO THE CAP THAT'S
APPROPRIATE FOR THAT REGION AND
WE THOUGHT THAT WAS.
ENTIRELY APPROPRIATE I'LL JUST
MENTION.
WE HAD CONTEMPLATED JUST SO YOU
HAVE A LITTLE BIT MORE OF A
SENSE OF THIS.
ABOUT WHETHER WE SHOULD GO WITH
SAY SINGLE NUMBER AS OPPOSED TO
A CPI PLUS NUMBER AND REALIZE
THAT CPI PLUS JUST PROVIDED MORE
OF THE ECONOMIC FLEXIBILITY. TO
TO ADDRESSES WE COULD HAVE SAID
AND A PERCENT CAP WHICH AT THIS
MOMENT IS EQUIVALENT OF SAY
STATEWIDE CPI PLUS FIVE BUT IT
JUST MADE MORE SENSE FOR US TO
TAILOR IT THIS WAY SO.
PART OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
IS SET A STATEWIDE POLICY BUT
WITH ENOUGH.
REGIONAL FLEXIBILITY TO TO TO
MEET NEEDS BUT AGAIN OUTLOOK FOR
TO WORKING WITH YOU AND AND
OTHERS TO WELL. TO TO FINE TUNE
THE WORK IN PROGRESS. TO GIVE
YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR AND
MISTER CHAIRMAN I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR HARD WORK ON
THIS BILL FOR THE VERY
THOUGHTFUL APPROACH THAT YOU'VE
TAKEN TO IT.
I KNOW WE HAD A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT AND I'M TO
BE PLEASED TO BE SUPPORTING IT
TODAY I THINK IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT WE CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION.
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE EXPRESSED
MUCH OF WHAT I WOULD WANT TO
CONVEY -- I JUST WANT TO SORT OF
EMPHASIZE TAKE A STEP BACK THAT
THIS IS THIS IS A REALLY BIG
STEP FORWARD -- IN THIS HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO REALLY MOVE THE
NEEDLE IN A VERY SERIOUS WAY AND
HELP A LOT OF FOLKS WHO NEED AND
DESERVE HELP.
AT THE SAME TIME BECAUSE THIS IS
SUCH A BIG STEP FORWARD IN
BECAUSE IT'S GOING.
TO AFFECT COMMUNITY STATEWIDE
MUCH BROADER THAN RENT CONTROL.
WE HAVE TO BE THOUGHTFUL BECAUSE
IT COULD HAVE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES AND IF IT'S NOT
DESIGNED CORRECTLY COULD MAKE
THE PROBLEM WORSE A COULD
EXACERBATE OUR SUPPLY PROBLEM SO.
I THINK THAT -- YOUR APPROACH
YOUR TO BE THOUGHTFUL TO TALK TO
FOLKS TO FOCUS ON THE TURNER
CENTER REPORT TO TASK FOR DATA
IS A REALLY REALLY.
POSITIVE ONE I THINK THAT WE
SHOULD BE MAKING DATA ARE WE
SHOULD BE MAKING POLICY BASED ON
EVIDENCE AND RESEARCH AND DATA.
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT YOU'VE
HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH ALL THE
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS I KNOW
THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF SPECIFIC
POINTS THE FOLKS HAVE ADDRESSED
CONCERNS AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS. TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION IN THAT RESPECT --
ALSO JUST ONE ECHO MY COLLEAGUES
WHEN IT COMES TO STABILITY I
THINK THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
DESERVE THAT I THINK THAT IT'S
UNFAIR TO RENTERS TO HAVE THINGS
PING PONG AROUND I THINK IT
WOULD SEND.
TERRIBLE MARKET SIGNALS AND
COULD EXACERBATE OUR SUPPLY
CHALLENGES THE FOR PING PONG
AROUND.
AND AND ALSO WON'T LET US KNOW
FOR WE'RE DOING IS WORKING RIGHT
WE WILL BE ABLE TO JUST
AGGREGATE WHAT POLICIES ARE
DOING THAT ARE ARE ROLLING THE
BALL FOR TO WHICH THINGS ARE
AREN'T HELPFUL SO -- I I KNOW
THAT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
SUPPORT YOU I KNOW THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT SUPPORT TO THE
OTHER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
BECAUSE I THINK EVERYBODY HAS
EXPRESSED THAT TODAY -- BUT I
JUST WANT TO APPLAUD YOU FOR
THIS VERY VERY SIGNIFICANT AND
BIG STEP FORWARD -- PLEASED TO
SUPPORT THE BILL AND REALLY
LOOKING FOR TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION SO WE CAN GET THIS
RIGHT AND HEALTH OF PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA -- I GUESS -- OF OF A
WRAP UP OF BEFORE OUT CHAIRMAN
MAKE HIS CLOSING REMARK -- YOU
KNOW I I KNOW THAT -- THE
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE TO HEAR
TODAY.
ALL GENUINE.
IS CHAIRMAN AND THAT YOU ARE
APPROACHING THIS ISSUE -- FROM
FROM A A FROM FROM A STANDPOINT
OF THOUGHT MALICE OF THAT YOU'RE
TRYING YOUR BEST TO DO WHAT YOU
THINK IS.
IS RIGHT FOR OUR STATE -- I JUST
WANNA OFFER -- AT A SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE OF SIR.
THAT.
AS A FORMER -- RENTER -- I KNOW
THAT IN THE IN THE EARLY
NINETIES WHERE.
MY PARENTS AND I WHEN WE SHARE A
ONE BEDROOM APARTMENT ON THE
CORNER OF UNIVERSITY COLLEGE IN
SAN DIEGO.
OF THE RENT AT THAT TIME.
IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE WAS
ABOUT SIX HUNDRED FIFTY BUCKS A
MONTH.
THE THE THE ISSUE OF OF OF RENT
CONTROL WOULD WOULD NEVER COME
UP AND NOT NOT IN OUR
NEIGHBORHOOD.
WE DIDN'T HAVE A A HOUSING
CRISIS WE DIDN'T HAVE A A CRISIS
OF OF PEOPLE FEEL THAT FEELING
LIKE THEY WERE BEING GALLAGHER --
EVERY MONTH -- AND SO SO SO HOW
DO WE HOW DO WE GET FROM THAT
POINT TO WHERE WE ARE NOW WHERE
SO MANY PEOPLE.
OF FUEL LIKE. 90% OF WHAT THEY
BRING HOME GOES INTO THEIR AND
LANDLORDS POCKETS.
AND AND AND I WOULD OFFER THAT --
JUST LIKE CLIMATE CHANGE -- THIS
IS A A A MAN MAY PROBLEM BECAUSE
OVER THE YEARS WHETHER IT WAS --
IT MAY BE ISM OR WHAT IT WAS --
GOVERNMENT OF POLICY FROM
SACRAMENTO OR FROM THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT HAVE.
DISCOURAGE PEOPLE FROM.
PUTTING MORE HOUSING UNIT ONLINE --
IS IT'S GOTTEN TO THE POINT
WHERE.
OF BUSINESS SHORTAGE AND THE
MARKET DICTATES SO THE PRICE
WHEN THERE'S A HOUSING SHORTAGE --
BY A UP.
I'M HOPEFUL THAT -- THROUGHOUT
THIS PROCESS -- SERMON THAT YOU
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION IN.
A COMING UP WITH A COMPROMISE
THAT.
NOT EVERYONE.
CAN BE HAPPY WITH BUT THEY CAN
LIVE WITH -- AND AND FOR THAT
I'M I'M GOING.
TO RESERVE MY VOTE OF TODAY --
AND I'M NOT GONNA VOTE FOR TODAY
AND AND HOPE THAT.
YOU'RE ABLE TO COME UP WITH SOME
SORT OF SOLUTION.
OF FOR IT ON THE FLOOR SO WITH
THAT -- YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU --
I'VE I'VE ALREADY EXPRESSED EACH
OF YOU BUT I JUST WANT TO SAY IT
AGAIN AND ALSO TO ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ENGAGEMENT.
I AND CERTAINLY THE ENGAGEMENT
IS NOT OVER WHEN THIS BILL
LEASES COMMITTEE WE WILL
CONTINUE TO DO AN AWFUL LOT OF
HARD WORK AND DISCUSSIONS IN THE
COMING DAYS AND WEEKS.
LET ME ALSO SAY AS YOU'VE HEARD
ME SAY BEFORE -- ADDRESSING THE
WORSE HOUSING CRISIS IN OUR
STATE'S HISTORY WILL TAKE ALL OF
THE ABOVE SOLUTIONS THIS IS NOT
A SILVER BULLET THIS BILL.
NOR IS -- FIGURE OUT HOW TO
TURBO CHARGED PRODUCTION -- IF
WE'RE ABLE TO PRODUCE MORE
PRESERVE MORE AND PROTECT.
OUR CONSTITUENCIES THE THREE
PIECE THAT WILL GET US THERE BUT
WE NEED TO DO ALL OF THEM AND WE
NEED TO DO ALL OF THEM AT ONCE.
I DO BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A
CRITICAL PORTION OF AN AGENDA
MOVING FORWARD PROTECTIONS OF
TENANTS ALTHOUGH I WILL SAY.
MY HOPE IS THAT WE WILL BE ABLE
BE ABLE IN THE COMING YEARS TO
THINK ABOUT HOW TO ASSIST.
INDIVIDUALS LIVING IN RENT
CONTROL JURISDICTIONS LIKE MINE
AS WELL AS INDIVIDUALS.
WHO ARE IN HONORING CONTROL
JURISDICTIONS FIFTEEN MILLION
RENTERS WHO COULD BE ASSISTED
BOTH BY THIS BILL AND OTHER?
MEASURES AROUND JUST BECAUSE
PROTECTIONS ECCENTRIC BUT ARE
FOR TODAY I AM VERY MUCH ASK AND
AND AND APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT
OF MOVING THIS BILL OUT -- I
LOOK FOR TO TO WORKING ENGAGING
WITH ALL OF YOU AS I'VE SAID
BEFORE THIS IS A BILL TO PROVIDE
CERTAINTY. TO FIFTEEN MILLION
CALIFORNIA RENTERS THAT THEY
WILL NOT RECEIVE AN EXORBITANT
RENT INCREASE WHILE ALLOWING
PROPERTY OWNERS TO MAKE A FAIR
RETURN ON THEIR INVESTMENT --
AND IT'S IMPORTANT WE MOVE THIS
FOR BECAUSE THE RENT IS TOO HIGH
WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
ABOUT.
THANK YOU A AND WE DO HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER GLORIA SECOND
BY MISS QUIRK SILVA THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
PORTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS TAPE [inaudible]
NOT VOTING.
GABRIEL.
GABRIEL ON A GLORIA.
GLORIA I KILEY.
KILEY NO.
LEE MON.
LIMóN I MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
I QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SHOULD TO SORRY.
HI [inaudible] SIX THE MOVE PASS
OUT THE THE HOUSING COMMITTEE ON
A SIX TO ONE VOTE THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES.
JOINT GAVEL DOWN YES -- MEETING
IS ADJOURNED